Man.
You're good.
No.
[inaudible] everybody.
This is a fight companion.
If you've never listened to one before.
We try to follow along with the fights,
but you never know where it's going to go.
Our captain of the ship,
Joe Rogan is in Vegas at UFC one 89 possibly the biggest UFC ever according to
Joe.
Is that right?
I say UFC 100 but what can you do?
What can you do?
Yeah,
sorry man.
We're 89 UFC.
It's away from that time.
We got a squad here tonight.
I'm excited for this one.
The Kid Cowen,
Bobby,
Bobby Lee's.
Your nickname,
if you a fighter.
Bobby.
Oh,
uh,
hey.
Yellow scallop yellow.
Scally Yay.
Yeah,
Dude.
That's because it's like,
I'm like a yellow fat.
You know me in person.
I know,
but like I have no formation.
Like I'm just feet formless,
but that doesn't sound very menacing.
If you were to like and Bobby,
scary yellow scallop,
I don't know.
Scallop.
I want to see SSC.
Yeah,
but what would be your technique?
Would you just be so amorphous that when you got hit like on my back and then I
bend over and then they just fuck me in the behind?
Well,
no,
a
porno set mode is,
although a lot of times guys get,
they sleep after they're done a different instructor then.
Cause that was the movie taught me.
I think your nickname should be Bobby.
Yeah.
Oh No,
that's racist.
I said come back to,
you know,
say you go.
How do we need to,
hey no,
I would assume in this room,
the person who knows probably the second most about the UFC is your girlfriend.
Khalilah passive participant.
I'm just going to chime in,
you know,
here and there.
It's always nice to have a nice voice on the mic.
That's for Kalina.
Your job is also,
besides me.
I mean obviously I'm good looking man,
but it just got a lot better.
Yeah.
I want to talk about who you think is the sexiest fighter in this,
in this whole group as you watch the fights.
Oh sure.
I can do that is a little bit weird.
Whoa.
Why'd you laugh so hard?
Hey,
whoa,
whoa.
The artists,
dude,
I'm with your brother.
Yeah,
she's into,
I mean,
I can't help the way God made me.
No,
I think you're a good looking dude.
There's nothing I could do with this.
You shouldn't it umbrella.
I think you look good.
Wait,
let me see.
You pulled an attractive lady.
What you pulled into the tractive ladies who didn't,
you know,
I,
she's a very attractive and she's like,
she's a good spirit and she has a great heart,
you know?
And also we met on Tinder and I wanted to have that true.
Yeah.
I wanted to have sexual intercourse with her first.
But then I realized that I loved her.
So then we had gotten into a relationship point of pride there that we met on
Tinder and I think it cheapens the entire relationship.
I disagree.
It's 2015 it's Tinder.
It's,
it's a hookup APP.
It's not like match.com going to say you're very hot and I have a small penis
when you're wearing the red Bandana.
And it makes me furious.
But I also want to go with a Bandana headband,
the head thing.
What are you doing?
Is that for sweat in your,
I don't know man.
My,
I don't know.
My hair is long.
It's uncontrollable even though,
cause I put it on.
Oh,
you sound like you had good.
He's suddenly got a Korean accent.
Uncle Brian,
you know your boy Matt Brown,
one tonight sweats to be fight of the night against the dirty bird.
He already fought.
Yeah man,
I didn't know I missed
the prelim.
Yeah.
So during the fight campaigns,
I feel like reaching across this and strangling during the fight means it's the
only the paper view percent.
Dammit.
So hold on,
hold please.
So Mack brown dirty,
he was a heck of a fight.
Not fight of the night with a heck of a right there.
That right there.
How long did it last?
Uh,
it was late in the first round.
There's like,
I think a minute or 30 seconds left for break.
Jamie.
Yeah,
that's a big win for Matt Brown.
Huge win.
I mean he's ranked number five.
I don't think two means is ranked,
but still match up wise Jesus.
Huge win.
Yeah.
Do you think that's psychological?
Do you see that pre fight thing where they were on stage together and then like
the other guy when they're weighing?
All right baby.
All right.
The way in,
I've got to ask that question the way it's been,
but you know how when you get into somebody's mindset if you like are like crazy
up there?
No,
no,
because you know,
I see the guy put his hand on his hip,
Robbie Lawler's face like that.
It does nothing.
It's all for show to hype.
The fight.
I would cry.
And so everybody,
everybody there knows there,
I mean no one's done that nothing's,
no one's worried about anything.
Literally.
It's like what?
You just want to wait and get out of there cause you know you're one day closer
to the fight.
Yeah.
That's when it things get real.
That's when you're like,
oh there's no turning back now.
That's where you get nervous.
Yeah.
Dan Brennan,
he's going to fight Andrea Laski and Andrea Lusk.
He's a monster.
He's fighting for the title and bread and being and by the way,
bees hairier than Callan.
Yeah.
And he said,
I said,
how are you feeling?
And Brendan goes scared and that's all he said.
I was like Jesus,
that's,
that's honesty right there.
Cause I still wear the mouth guard with the,
with the fangs.
He's one of my favorite fighters.
Yeah he does.
Yeah.
I was on the wrestling team in high school.
I used to get really nervous before meets and stuff.
Hell yeah.
Really nervous.
Anything one on one even.
I'm sure you got nervous before you do stand up when you started,
when you first started out.
But the lesson was still more nerve wracking for me because I was a kid.
I didn't know how to deal with that kind of pressure.
It really,
yeah man.
Cause horrible.
I'll tell you what I am digging is the new layout of the UFC.
The design,
it's a lot.
Everything's a lot cleaner.
Like the graphics are cleaner.
It's a lot more professional.
I liked that you,
you'll see when the,
cause it's the,
so just let everyone know.
So this is the first night that the guys are wearing the Reebok kits as they
call them.
So there you can't have any other sponsors.
The fighters have to these designated
Reebok kits.
So everything looks a lot cleaner off.
See the graphics are a lot cleaner.
I love the look.
What I don't like is the octagon looks like a NASCAR now.
So now the fighters look cleaner,
but the octagon is dirtier in the arts.
All the ads on the wait,
wait,
TC locked again.
There's,
there's liberty 10 spot,
there's ads everywhere,
but then the filers super clean.
So the only issue I have with that,
I love the whole look of the UFC.
I'm actually nightmare mad at the kids cause it's super clean looking.
But now the AUC gun looks dirty and then when you have all those sponsors,
no one's seen any of that money.
The fighters aren't seeing the money.
So for the UFC it's great.
Before the guys with the talent inside.com they're not seeing any of that.
That's the issue I have.
Right.
But I'm sure at times a change,
however,
the look I approve.
Surprisingly,
I approve.
I thought people were and thing I was going to hate on it.
Not at all actually.
Like the cleaner look,
it looks more like the NFL or Nhl,
which is what they're going for.
I get supports growing and uh,
know here it is.
Look it.
Mr Picot people are crunk for this flight.
Pretty crunk.
I,
he um,
I hung out with him.
He came to my show in Florida with Jaguar guavas and some,
uh,
and Matt Brown and Mike Brown is your friend now.
Are you gonna say I was,
I was loving it because he's not a big guy,
but he dresses very well.
He was wearing a hat,
a hat on,
right.
Had it had it,
had a beautiful,
beautiful polo on and I think it was a pink polo and I was like so low.
There's a small Badass,
not afraid to wear a pink Polo.
I was very impressed with him and it was a,
I was in first class helps with employer Gracie.
Ooh.
And then when we landed in New York,
I asked him for a hug and he hugged me.
Really?
It was a cooler,
but I didn't say anything the whole flight because it's sort of intimidated,
you know,
if it was Hixon I would,
I would have not said anything at all.
But it was heuler he's,
you know,
he's gentler.
Luckily I saw Hixson Hixson his time piece at Siff Pacific Greens about 10 years
ago.
I couldn't understand how it was that good looking look like a superhero.
And I said,
I didn't know what to say.
So I go a hex and high.
I used to train with hand.
So,
and you said it like that?
Yeah,
he could probably give us the most,
he was handsome.
Okay.
Beat it has be it pimp along,
don't they?
Or they don't?
Uh,
I don't know exactly the ratio.
I'm sure.
Hickson's a beast.
He's a beast deuce.
He's reached by the best looking one.
Let's be honest.
Him or Henner.
Why was it good looking?
Did you see it headed to study?
Of course.
I'm not saying studs.
I'm saying good luck.
Your grace.
A Henna.
C'Mon Henderson.
Six four with a Calvin Klein.
I six five probably killed about six five six,
five.
Who Do you guys can the best looking guy off?
UFC is,
who's the best looking guy now you'll crack hold a brand shops up there.
I don't know if I'm up there.
Top three pretty pretty.
It's not like
you're a hot dude.
Brooks brother.
He looks like a 1950 is doorman
Detroit and then I think I can say that 100% Puerto Rican.
I looked like I wrangled tigers.
That's what I look.
Watch
TV.
Yeah.
Maybe you need a mustache.
You look like if you had a mustache.
He look like one of those 1920 strong men.
Yeah.
I like to go the old school here.
Cut.
I like the Great Gatsby to what inspired this?
I want to say that unless you're chuck by Dell,
you're not allowed to have a Mohawk who,
this is not this guy,
his trainer,
Bro.
If you're 40 you can't have a Mohawk.
You just can't.
I agree.
Unless you're chuckling.
Roy McDonald goes with the same haircut.
I'll tell you what,
as far as marketing goes,
not feeling that haircut.
Roy and Roy is my boy and you know,
and you know marketing.
What?
Why,
why do you not like that for him?
He's clean.
You want them clean cut.
Like clean cut or you know Roy dresses well speaks well he's a little
introverted but you know he speaks.
Wow Man.
So why not do it up with the hair man?
Grow it.
Brad Pickett.
This dressed like flee.
I don't like it.
Yeah.
He plays Bass for a band that is flea.
He doubles his Brad Pickett.
He didn't.
I'll tell you what though.
This little dude can punch.
He can hit.
Yes.
He can box his ass off.
Well he starts,
I guess that was his first discipline.
Boxing.
Yeah.
Tiny little dude.
He's a small guy.
Like those Reebok kids.
What do you think?
Ah,
I don't mind him.
Um,
I don't,
I don't really have a strong opinion.
No,
I'm liking Mike Brown's beard.
That guy,
that former WC world champion,
he was a stud back in the day and true stud superseding.
It reminds me of communism,
that the colors and stuff and the,
and the kids.
Well,
and the way you're not far off the mark because if you have to wear something,
the fighters no longer it can be sponsored.
Right.
So they can't wear sponsors.
Nate.
There money isn't as,
they don't make any money anymore.
Right.
Stuff.
How about that cut man utility vest those guys have on where I didn't see it.
Oh Wow.
Cause they used to have their own stuff.
Right.
Stitch used to definitely have his own stuff.
Stitch is a little stitch might be more famous than a lot of fighters.
The cut man stitch you see mean Klitschkos corner and you see him everyone's
corner.
Let's go fight without stitch.
You know that?
Yeah.
Stitches his stitches.
The cut man.
That's a human being stitch.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
His real name's uh,
I think a stitch Duran.
I don't know his real first name,
but he's like the nicest guy ever.
He works.
He works with the best of the best.
Like there's some guys will schedule their fights around.
So stitching Klitschkos one of them.
Now you walk out here,
your,
your emotions are all over the place,
right?
No,
here you're good because here you're good.
You touched gloves and it's just this go Tesco almost in cruise control.
For me,
I would just need to get like three minutes past the first round and I'm good.
Right to three.
But trouble before then.
Cause you're,
you're so nervous,
you know you're making,
you can kind of make mistakes.
You can see the pros kind of chill out.
They calmed down and they feel it out a little bit.
Heavyweights is really no feeling out.
Can I ask you something?
Do you know,
do you know your mom inches by?
I already know I googled it,
but uh,
do you know where your mom and your girlfriend and stuff are when you're in the
ring or no,
not a clue.
I frills.
I know where Brian's at.
That's it.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh that's weird.
I wouldn't know.
Like I would be like in my head,
like mom's on the third row lives.
I have no idea.
You can't think that way.
Why?
And I,
and,
and I would imagine you're the bulk of the nerves is that you just want to
perform well.
It's not about getting hurt,
you know,
you,
I don't even think about getting hurt.
I just want to,
when I'm more nervous about losing this.
But do you know you're losing when you're losing?
No.
I always think I was every,
every time I thought I was winning,
what if I didn't get stopped?
Obviously,
but if it goes past the first round,
I always thought I was winning every single fight or Lassi,
I thought,
no question.
I want to fight without a doubt.
I was like,
oh.
Even Rogan came in was like,
I think you got it.
And then when I went the other way,
everyone was like,
what?
And that's where the crowd was booing.
Yup.
Yeah.
Fight Game Vancouver.
That's my fault for leaving to the judges.
Not the best performance that's on me.
Well,
you're forgiven.
Thank you,
sir.
England.
Brad Pickett,
the caddies.
Fighting's undefeated 19 and now I bet you that your coaches are more nervous at
this point.
A big job.
It's a tight shirt.
Big Gun.
Got a set of tits,
tits on him.
I love him.
He's the best.
He's my favorite record.
He's also a cop.
I love it.
Yeah.
He's a Badass.
He's the best.
We got by far the best we got.
Awesome.
He's so intense in the back when he comes back his oh man.
Super intense.
Really?
I think,
I think pickets.
The biggest underdog on the main card.
I think he's plus five 50 the caddies fighting this Brazilian now meet us 19 and
oh man.
Doing something right.
If you're 19 and now,
unless you fight and keeps his hands,
how to puffs.
There he is.
Look at them.
Yeah.
Mine is six 60 I mean,
what?
What's the point of embedding w w explain what minus six 60th.
I'm an idiot.
When it comes to gap.
You'd have to put $660 not to win a hundred.
Wow.
That's a,
that's a bad day.
That's ridiculous.
I can't believe Robbie Lawler is the underdog.
You know what?
I get it.
You know why?
Because Roy can wrestle.
He did meet him before.
I know.
I know,
I agree.
I tell you what,
I would not want to be an odds maker in Vegas that that does fighting odds.
Why?
Because like Connor,
Chad,
it's a 12 what?
12 Day notice,
right?
Right around 12 day notice.
You got to make those odds.
We don't know what Chad was doing.
Did He,
was he eating camp training?
Cause I know Chad,
the thing about chat is he'll take some time off.
He's known to take time off and then going to camp when he has a funny,
now that I didn't know it takes time.
He's known as a guy that hunts and take some time off.
So was he in camp or did you get the call and he's playing grab ass with wart
hogs and wherever and it was like,
shit,
I better get in there 12 days.
I'll fight Sean
and 12 days.
Not The people who set the odds are privy to that type of information.
No,
that's the thing.
That's why betting on findings tough.
I'm very nervous about the Conor McGregor fight and Ooh,
but what made me,
what makes me nervous about the Conor fight?
My my heart.
I want Connor to when he's the best thing that happened in the UFC and the long,
long time since Brock Lesnar by far great lefthand bang.
And by the way,
super banging.
But uh,
did you see Conor during the Wayne's he was drawn the fuck.
Hey.
Wow,
look very,
he looked like Dallas buyers club sunglasses throughout the whole thing.
And I was wondering why and a nice saw.
Hello?
Picking big left hand.
Oh,
don't,
no,
we take him down.
Gets a chance to recover.
It's a bad idea.
Well,
he's an MMA fighter,
Brian.
Don't ever stop.
Come on.
Don't take them down.
There you go.
Come on.
Oh.
Oh No,
no,
no.
He's out.
No,
let him stand up,
man.
He's rock.
Okay.
See You guy can recover when you do this.
Oh yeah.
Well he really took him out there.
Wow.
He's still not right.
He's not right.
We don't want to rush in B.
Right.
He's being patient is being patient.
It's called being a pro.
It's called being a pro brand.
Lead.
Me.
I've rushed in there.
Brian Callahan paid a price.
Eight a deep deep pricing.
It's a guy named Ben Rothwell.
He's number six in the world now.
God dammit.
So what's picket feeling right now?
What is he thinking?
He's staying calm.
You know he,
he's deaf.
He knows he's winning the fight and the exchanges.
So pickets getting momentum here.
And it's weird.
It's like your gas tank comes back.
Even if you're tired and you rock the guy,
you're like,
damn.
You don't even think about getting tired.
Is he happy that he's bleeding?
Does he think to himself?
Yeah,
he's loving the way.
Pick it like his angles and stuff.
Look at it.
Oh Wow.
This is a fight.
There's a good fight.
Wow.
Damn ma'am.
Oo,
he's rocked.
Wow.
What a great fire.
Jesus.
Oh,
taking a stance right there.
Look at us.
Tell you what for when the biggest Oh,
for one of the biggest UFC fights of all time cards of all times.
Exactly how you want to start this thing off.
Oh,
snaps.
There's a reason these boys kicked this fight off or cart off.
Keep your hands up.
Wow.
Tell you what,
my man,
I'll meet it.
Came back here.
He's a tough round of score.
Super tough friends.
I would still give it to pick it.
Got Call him twice.
Come twice.
Well it was still a minute left.
That's a lot of time to change.
You see what I'm saying about the octagon though?
Yes.
So the Octonauts Nascar,
but the fighters are clean now,
so he just flipped the script.
So now the UFC,
you know,
by the way,
they're wearing the same shorts kind of,
right?
I mean it's to say,
well one guy
in the white,
I don't to why I don't think you should do white and black.
I think one guy should be in all red.
And when guys,
she'd be an all blue blue or all black,
right?
Cause the gloves,
the gloves that's going out because the corners are red and blue.
Right.
So we have the shorts.
Red and blue did distinct between the two cause they look very fucking similar.
It's very confused.
I really do.
Oh Oh stats.
Pickets got,
he's punching on angles here,
right,
Brendan and what's he doing here?
So,
yeah,
I love a boxer,
man.
I said little detailed.
He's slipping like he's standing there and able to see that
my boy on meters frickin winning the tans throwing.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
oh,
great fight.
Ooh.
What a round.
A ground.
Rouse.
Look at them.
Chase God.
Rebound.
Good for Reebok for them.
I know a long way from Reebok pumps.
Um,
way.
When did they even start making?
Right now,
this is the first one.
Yeah,
this is the first fight.
I'll tell you what though.
I like,
I like the clean look.
I like the,
um,
you know,
I've been really outspoken.
I don't like Reebok,
but I like the clean look.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
It looks better now about the octagon is messy.
Uniformity.
I liked the uniform,
but I wished it,
what I think we should have done is said,
all right.
Reeboks gonna supply you guys with all this gear.
You can,
if any other sponsors just know apparel sponsors.
Again,
if anything else,
we know apparel,
so now the fighters look basic,
but the octagon looks like a fucking taxi cab with those looks like a Jackson
Pollock painting as they say,
Hey,
is there any way we can we be more ring girls?
I cause I don't think four's enough.
Can we get eight?
Is there any way we can get a tiredness?
These guys or these guys are doing it here too,
and it,
where were you going to say you're going to say,
these guys are sweating a tough
boy.
These guys are fighting.
They're fighting Brian and throw that in every now and then.
Boy,
these guys are breathing the way he's moving Brennan.
You know what I'm doing?
Ask me what I'm doing on my watch.
This fight.
You're acting like you're moving,
studying.
You're studying them.
Oh,
oh,
oh wow.
20 you know 20 no.
Can we write this guy in the top 15 wow.
Good.
That's a perfect example of what you just said.
First round,
sort of a little bit tentative and then he just picked it up.
Oh yeah.
That's what's heartbreaking about this sport,
man.
That's such a good job in gets caught with a knee.
It's just at this level.
Even at,
even at this weight,
there's just no room for error.
Matt take one time often it's just,
I'm not saying pig.
It took time off,
but there's just,
there's no gap for it.
It really sports that you can kind of get away with it.
Boom.
God,
Great.
Stop by.
I'm going to stop by McCarthy.
I agree 100% you have here you have evil Levine ass whoop sun down at the bottom
there.
That's evil Levine.
You're,
you're in trouble because he's like,
yeah,
that's not good for his head.
Oh Shit.
I don't like that.
Louis,
what do you mean chat?
If if evil of comes in the bags like I'm going to be your referee referee
tonight.
I go off shit.
Who's the most prudent McCarthy's the best in the business and McCarthy usually
does a,
I bet he's the main event guy.
Mccarthy.
He usually does the big fights because he's so damn good.
There's not too much controversy with McCarthy,
but Pika got back up though.
I mean,
he didn't die.
Why did they stop it?
He was out a couple more minutes.
Let it die too.
I think he got,
oh,
they sound like he was like,
no,
he was fucked up.
He was super fun because
I don't even know what that word.
Let me tell you this right now.
The guy got up and he deserves it.
Two more minutes that that's some boxing shit.
So box and you get dropped like that.
Or Ref comes up and goes one,
two so you can kind of gather your shit.
That's why you get horrible brain dead.
That's why the UFC safe.
Just saying the ratings would go up a little bit more if he goes to a male.
If you took out a knife,
there should be nice personally not so what you're saying is that he got up
because of gut instinct,
like just his body,
his car.
He got knocked down in his feet.
He landed on the ground.
He was out and then he came,
came to look why interest to let a phenomenal fight though.
Phenomenal,
phenomenal,
great left ticket,
had did a great job.
He just got caught and against a great.
Now is there any way we could spray paint some more sponsors?
I mean,
I see a couple areas.
Oh,
valuable real estate,
right?
So how much that costs monster.
Oh,
they'd probably cost them millions just to rent that space.
Not Cheap.
They can do it on my chest if they want for that kind of money.
Is this a bad deal for fighters then that they're made to where I'll Reebok for
Brendan?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I figured because,
because typically when a transition,
you become a fighter who is got a following like Brennan or if you're a fighter
that has,
um,
really anyone you can,
where you can make cut deals with various companies and say,
give me 40 grand and I'll wear this tee shirt or whatever and oh,
but Brian can,
they were like their own spunk ship during like interviews or low,
not the week of not the weekend.
Well,
that's not fair.
How is that fair?
That's life.
My man.
It's out of our,
if you want to be a fighter,
you typically I play by they on a money.
You probably don't want to be an MMA fighter.
Well here the exception like you can be a 1% or
like the u s a female World Cup soccer team.
Yeah,
they make what?
50 $60,000 a year then?
Not that a lot of money but the reason why,
what's that chick's name?
The hot one.
What's her name?
Alex Morgan.
Three 400 500,000 because of awesome.
Lots of judgments but she's not wearing those endorsements on the,
on the soccer field.
She's getting it from Gatorade,
right?
Nike all that out of the commercial.
Yeah.
A woman is a good guy,
man.
Yeah.
Is He your Buddy Brian?
I hung out with him and he was like cool.
So no,
he didn't match.
He did a couple of times.
Well did a really nice guy cause he's still at cause that 70 show he's killing
it on that 70 shell right.
Act as much.
He's more into politics.
He's thinking about going into politics and he's like well because it shows got
syndicated so he's just getting boat loads of money because your,
she'll get syndicated.
You're balling 70 show.
Think how big that was.
Semi me shows how much you think guys like that make now though.
I don't know how.
What are the best 70 shot?
He probably makes it residual wise.
Yeah.
He could probably make a couple hundred thousand maybe a hundred dollars a year.
Yeah,
that's it.
Wow.
More than that.
You'd be surprised.
Yeah.
Ashton Kutcher's ball in though and he leaves toy show.
Yeah,
he's on two and half men though.
Right?
He's making,
he also has a lot of other businesses.
Yeah.
Airbnb,
Twitter and AIRBNB.
When it first started,
only a few people full Chadman Eric Stonestreet and he's making a shitload of
money,
you know stone street.
Which one?
See,
he's on modern family.
He plays Cam.
The fact that fat gay guy,
is he gay in real life?
No,
but the redhead is
Paige.
Vanna ants in the back.
Not Mad at her at all.
Super Pretty.
It's hard for me to watch her get punched in the face.
There's the man of the hour.
Love the suit.
Love it.
Look at him,
look at him.
Look at her five year olds by fights in the UFC and he's the biggest star.
How cool is that?
He's awesome because he backs it up well tonight.
His head right now,
Brennan,
you can't get in there,
but what do you think if you had to guess as a fighter,
a for him?
Man,
he's a different animal man.
I think he's just excited to get in there,
you know.
Oh,
can we turn the sound off on it?
On it up on this?
I think we're good,
Brian.
For a commercial.
We're good.
Don't ever listen to Brian on sound.
Ah,
boom.
I think Rhonda is the most dominant female mixed martial arts athlete,
but I think,
uh,
Serena Williams is the most dominant she mailed last week.
She just won Wimbledon.
Yes.
She wants,
she wants today.
And think about the competition she's facing worldwide.
Worldwide.
Oh,
everywhere.
I'm from Russia,
I think our record this year or something like 45 and one and she,
and the thing is she's competing all the time.
Nonstop.
Rhonda can beats twice a year,
right?
Like Batch Korea.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's a tough sell,
man.
That's a fucking Tufts.
So like,
like Serena is going to war.
She's going on with the four and five hours.
How long has tennis been around?
Women's tennis is a big deal.
Yes.
So the,
the,
the competition is way higher than women's MMA.
I'm not hating on Rhonda.
We all know,
I love considered,
I considered and she's considered the best female tennis player ever and ever.
But so when,
when sports illustrated said Ronda Rousey best dot most dominant female athlete
of all time.
I disagree at Serena Williams by something.
Yes,
go ahead.
Go ahead,
sir.
I did a sketch with Serena Williams and she's very nice,
but she smelled funny.
That's all I have to say.
Well that's right.
That's right.
I didn't say that she would know that.
Nothing to do with that.
She's not funny.
Why was it possible that she ate some?
No,
we did a sketch where we play tennis.
Right.
And then I took a photo with her and she smelled funny.
That's all I'm saying.
What do you mean like shit,
not like hockey.
Blood.
Like hot blood.
Yeah,
like that might be tested.
It was curdled like hurdle blood.
I've never smelt curdle blood either of.
Oh,
what would you compare it to?
Like,
yeah,
well it's like maybe spam.
Everybody's cost money sometimes,
but listen.
All right,
well it wasn't of thing.
I have not,
I have nothing against.
It's just twisting words around.
She smells like dog.
She's a nice person.
That's all she smelled funny.
Move on.
Hey,
I'll tell you what.
She's too much for you.
Count.
Oh,
100% too much.
Are you kidding Bobby Lee?
Too much for you.
Have a conversation with [inaudible].
I was looking at harassing her legs and her arms.
I was like,
well,
you're,
I'm way too light in the ass.
No,
no,
no.
I went to,
uh,
it was in Miami.
He was,
I liked like the Miami open or something like that and I knew her agent and they
brought me in the back while she's warming up and I was like,
Jesus Christ,
she's too much for me.
Yeah.
She's too much of an animal and you're a big,
you need to make love to,
is that what you're saying?
Take it on the sheets and then toss me around like a baton,
like a circus.
Bhutan.
She would eat you like a sardine.
You're not.
You're an appetizer.
You're wasting your fucking time alone is the size of your waist.
I saw her at the Australian Open in Melbourne.
Yeah,
she is so just beautifully muscular.
She's prettier though.
She's super pretty,
very pretty face.
She's just,
I smelled her and she has some,
she smelled like apricots,
old biddies.
I wouldn't be able to in a blog ass blow out as an athletic,
more athletic than anyone.
You could rest all your books,
all your books on that ass.
That is a,
she can handle this.
It's,
she's too much for me,
which I've never said that before in my life,
but she's too much.
She's way too much.
She,
she for her,
she did it in Lavonne Arrington for a couple of minutes of Arlington and then
he's the boy Williams,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
She did date come and good call.
He's small.
He's probably whispering and there's some fucking poems and shit or he's
driving.
He's riding high and he's riding high and deep and true.
Coming us that Tana Guana Dick,
100% looks like go boy.
Brands that so at wish nightclub in Denver,
Colorado.
The security team was myself,
Brandon thatch and Cody Donovan.
That was a security team.
That's it.
That's a problem.
I don't want any trouble with any of that.
I don't want to cause any prop.
Right.
And His dad is known fricking around Denver.
He's such a baddest,
there's pressure on Brandon grown up cause his dad clearance,
that was such a bad ass in Denver.
Kickboxer ran a gym.
He trained his son since he was little.
So Brandon's always been kind of this,
he's been the guy in the gym who was never super dedicated,
but he was the most talented by far.
And I'd always say if that kid ever got his shit together,
he's going to be champion one day he's going to be a monster.
Does he have his shit together?
He has his shit together.
He got his shit together.
He's in the UFC right now.
Does he suck that much way?
Was he walking around huge.
He's huge.
Man.
I mean he's,
he's God.
I can't remember last time.
So you know he's the biggest welterweight.
I know he's bigger than St pier by far.
Jesus by far,
st period used to fly thatch up when he was getting ready for condit,
St pier would fly thatch up.
That just standup is second to none really.
If he can get comfortable with second to none.
You,
you weren't talking about a ladies man.
If you're talking about,
if you're talking about the Frickin CEO of black belts and chicken heads,
is that right?
She's the CEO.
I'm an intern.
Can painting.
You see his body boy,
his boss guys,
Cutie.
He's a cutie pie was more girls than I do.
Really?
100% this guy,
he's got narrow shoulders.
You know why he's a raver.
He was a braver forever before,
before fights in Denver.
This fool would turn on like numb checks with flames.
I swear to God and he goes out.
Wow.
Dime piece the way he's talked to grow a powerful least her bowling.
That's Elliot Marshall,
my good buddy and that's Christian now and my first coach.
Where's Lester balling?
Elisa Bowlin's right there.
Okay.
These,
the sh the guy who looks like a fire hydrant with there's wrestler,
phenomenal wrestler.
He was the head coach for GSP,
for wrestling myself.
Shank Carlin named Mark Cart.
You're talking about the cream of the crop at least,
or bowling man.
They don't get better than him.
The old man behind them is Edward James Olmos.
That's exactly right.
I shaved his head.
And then Elliot Marshall,
he runs a Easton's in Denver.
He's a black belt.
Compete in Jiu Jitsu forever compete in the UFC.
And then to the left description,
Allen,
who is fat just striking coach.
I'm telling if that can get loose,
you're gonna see a crazy ass knocked out tonight if he gets comfortable.
I've seen this boy do some shit and he's like,
listen to this.
He's like a giant Anthony Pettis.
He can go both ways.
He knew Orthodox and Orthodox.
He's crazy.
Southport,
whatever.
Look how big he is.
He's big.
But you know if there's an Achilles heel to brand fest,
you know it is.
I can say what it is.
Go ahead.
My guess is that he,
he can be,
he's easily broken.
No,
goddammit.
No card.
No Paul Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
He's been working on,
it meant Jujitsu.
He's never been a guy that I had to attack his character.
He's a good guy.
I don't know all my breaks.
Easy.
Yeah,
man.
He's on one of the biggest UFC fight cards of the year because the brakes,
he's like,
that's so funny.
He's a B.
Brandon's friends with somebody.
He's going to defend him to the fucking death.
This is true.
You were friends now I got,
you know,
walked.
I'll come to laugh,
act and slept some.
Got Brendan.
I'll beat up.
Everybody know this guy right here though.
What's phenomenal,
Jujitsu.
But he has gotten really pretty eyes.
His eyes are nice.
Oh,
very close friend.
That's why everyone's cheering for him.
The only time we should turn this up is when Connor walks out.
That's the only time.
Well,
you want Trump to know,
oh,
turn this Carl's junior commercial up.
I like,
I like commercials.
Uh,
if this fight goes to the ground,
I'm a little worried about it.
Good luck in Sachse down though.
It's good luck getting them down for how phenomenal.
Take down defense.
Crazy.
Nice.
Yikes.
He's got to know that too.
I don't,
I don't know how one goes in there and you're fighting a monster and he's going
to try to knee and kick and punch your head off and they're really no gloves.
Well,
the thing is,
when your Jujitsu is as good as Gunnar Nelson,
you've beat guys like Jeff Monson.
You're not too concerned about,
you know,
like he's been,
he's been there were tough guys.
It doesn't matter if it's taken every opponent down.
Um,
yeah.
He's never find a guy like Thatcher in the UFC.
Not even close.
I think it was last night.
It was Rick story,
right?
He lasts my decision.
I think it was a close decision.
You lost a rich body.
That's,
that's a body that has never done steroids.
Right there.
Story actually was able to take them down.
You're not gonna see how,
you know what factors wrestling's not bad at all.
I wouldn't be surprised with that.
She takes none.
Just makes it go for no so much.
I'm a pastor.
Maybe use know much.
You go,
girl,
no more than Brian.
Hey,
fuck you man.
[inaudible]
hot girl.
Brian fighter in the hot girl.
Your girlfriend's very hot by the gay.
Now some of them,
a lot of sex going on.
Hey
Dude,
by the way,
brand that's six to,
that's no joke.
He's huge.
But look,
the re only a two and a half inch reach advantage.
What does he suck down from
210 pounds?
Wow and shredded Jesus.
Satch is a monster man.
My Colorado Boys.
Proud of those guys.
I love those guys.
What's the Black Guy's name?
Herb Gray.
What's his name?
Dean.
That's it.
I call him Harry Dean hot.
I'm not going to lie to you guys.
I heard herb has a pterodactyl Dick.
You know how straight up there's still room or around the,
around the fight club.
My man.
Well of course he does.
Let's see,
I don't,
I want to say Kevin,
what's that mean?
I mean he's
a what?
How tall is he?
Six.
He's 66 he's 97 47 67.66 something right.
And he's a big African American.
It doesn't matter you.
They have a little one.
Well know Shaquille O'neil.
They say he has a baby bird dick.
That's what everyone says.
His ex girlfriend came out as a joke.
There's actually a friend of mine dated a guy in the UFC who is,
I'm black and he,
she says he's hung like a field mouse.
Oh,
which one is it?
We'll talk about it off here.
I spotted Arnold Schwarzenegger in the crowd.
He loves [inaudible].
Here we go.
Look at gunner.
Gunner.
Well,
he's used to going with Connor,
so he's,
he's going to see some kicks.
Connor's Chin and talked about a clash of styles.
Come on.
Thatchy that's got a dome on him.
Big Head.
Big head
hesitate.
Well the take down my man.
Yeah,
I've got gotta be careful.
I'm just trying to get him to the cage.
Oh,
ouch.
That hurt a lot of ink.
You know what it looks like.
He's just rocking box underneath those probably not athletic undies.
I said,
we're in a cup.
Yes,
you have to work up.
Oh.
I'm telling you man.
Wait for that.
You get comfortable.
You can't basis is fight skills off that Ben Henderson fight couldn't be a worse
match up for the guy.
Oh my God.
Well also Ben Hanson is a monster.
Ben Henderson's a 1%.
I'll tell you what you don't want to do.
Get in the clinch.
Brandon Thatch.
If I'm [inaudible] he's,
and you're up more ties his shit.
My man,
Jesus thatching cowboys started more type fricking in diapers.
Everybody say buddy.
Super Buddies.
Yeah.
I loved cowboy.
Hey,
I want to get Kevin to come out to the show in Denver.
Yeah,
probably not man.
You know he came last time.
Yeah.
Not this time.
You don't know anything.
Just talk to them.
That's a big commitment on the old,
uh,
on your leg.
On the old leg.
Yeah.
Powerful.
Josh Ford does a lot of zinc.
Boy.
Boy,
they're both hesitant,
right?
This is what happens when you get cut.
Oh No.
Oh Shit.
Worst case scenario,
full mount.
Just blasting the face.
He relaxed any,
it took a little bit of time on that was,
I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you what not good.
And when you got Gunnar Nelson in half guard couldn't be worse for Brandon
Thatch right now.
Ouch.
Oh boy.
So I control,
Ooh.
And we're not talking about just a regular old black belt here.
We're talking about a guy who's competed in one.
I mean some serious competitions and Jujitsu.
Got Her.
Nelson is a phenom on the ground.
Yeah,
he's,
he's in full amount on Brad Thatch.
Well,
if someone said,
hey,
what's the worst case scenario for?
That's that's,
I'm like,
well I'd say mid.
What his brand is has to do with his hands.
Is that what he's doing?
Supposed to do a,
well you can't,
what he can't do is grab around the body.
But you got to realize that a lot of guys were naked.
Oh No.
See I don't like the body lock.
Nope.
The hear me out here.
Joe Disagrees.
If Rogan was here,
we'd be talking to him about this.
But the body life doesn't allow you to,
to move.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you're not going to advance and awesome.
And also you got to remember thatches rocked.
So this is GIM.
Thats a little bit of opportunity to,
although he's not and he's not going to do it with one hand,
two hands.
Oh God.
Oh Man.
Wow.
Fight by Gunnar Nelson.
Hey,
remember that time I hyped up a guy for an hour and then he got his ass whooped.
Yeah,
that just happened.
Hey,
it happens.
I don't trust you anymore.
You shouldn't.
I lost faith in,
you know,
if a friends fighting never listened to me.
Oh,
she's a monster though.
Nelson was the underdog,
right?
Yeah.
Barely.
That's a a,
that's a,
that's two in a row for that.
Yeah.
It's a tough,
tough.
Matchups man.
Too many raves.
Ah,
hopefully it's not raining some more.
Please not raving anymore.
Let's see what happened here.
Boom.
Hands down.
He was looking
straight,
right Sam?
It
change.
Oh boy.
He didn't think he wasn't thinking.
Momentary lapse of concentration and then a lot of guys,
why do you do this?
Brendon,
you should never do this,
right.
Well,
no.
A lot of guys who don't have a big Jujitsu base go to all fours because that's
what you do in wrestling and stand up.
You got all fours,
you stand up,
you have the high level grappler.
He wants you to turn that way because now that he's on your back you got
trouble.
Now he shouldn't have let them get this either but I should have been doing two
on one on the glove that he let that get around his neck and it was just all
over it again man.
That's if you're not training Jujitsu a ton.
When you get in those situations you don't paint so it's not second nature.
If you're down there,
go with high level guys a lot.
It's going to be second nature.
He has my back.
I might be a little rock.
I got to go two on one cause I'm gonna Control Control two on one or two hands
on one.
Here's where I'm confused.
If you know you're fighting a monster like Gunnar Nelson worrying out,
rolling with high level gods and he probably is,
especially if Elliot Marcia says,
coach,
you're rolling with black belts.
But if it's a seven week camp and Gunnar Nelson's been translating how long this
is language.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Shit.
That's a bummer man.
It's just hard fight.
But a huge wind by gunner praying and had some shit to look in the mirror.
Man,
that's a tough law.
Now tonight is he,
does he cry?
I mean,
do you cry when you lose like that?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you don't want to talk to anyone?
Do you got certain guys?
Take it different.
Like Alistair Overeem,
he's lost and he'll tweet out like gap part of the game and then you seem,
you seem gentle so you seem like you would cry.
Oh,
I'm in a ball crying ground.
Thanks Bro.
Hold on.
Hold on baby.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hey Bobby,
what's your hands?
Thanks man.
Yeah,
I don't deal with lots of things that great left.
Oh God.
On the chin.
The thing,
if you're in that range,
why are your hands down and Chin up?
He talks about a high level striker here.
I just don't think he respected his striking.
It looks like he stepped back to reset.
Like he stepped down and who didn't step back though.
He just like,
I don't know.
It'd be,
maybe he thought dunner was going to step back.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
He misread something.
Yeah.
That's tough.
You get in those habits when you spar sometimes,
right?
With a hundred percent a hundred percent you get in those bad habits,
man,
cause you,
you reset.
Your buddy's not going to hit you.
Now you're in a fight.
Tell you what's trouble though.
Guess who's boy that is Connor.
You don't think that's a huge motivation.
Boost your boy who you went through this entire camp with and then he just
dominated the biggest fight of his career.
Amazing,
powerful champion and Chris Weidman tell you what you wanna my favorite girl
fighter.
Best striker in the world for women.
A killer.
Did you say your killer?
No.
I said,
oh killer Jesus.
Maybe it is.
All of these guys.
Damn rough have,
I'll take this audience looks just as big as him and he fights at 55 and he's
definitely not as big as he looks at it now.
Definitely not.
Nope.
This guy seems humble.
Yeah,
super humble.
He like celebrate
the Brian Kelly.
You've seen Gunnar Nelson Aka the kid of the UFC.
Like grow my beard pretty big.
I might grow a big beard.
Have you ever had a big beard?
No,
but I,
but I'm looking at these guys and I'm feeling like I need to.
Bobby,
have you ever had a big,
I can't look at me.
This is 22 years of growth right here.
It looks like ants attack and my mouth cause 15 here's her fellow and my pubes.
They don't curl it straight.
They go straight out.
It's not because I'm scared like it's constantly scared.
So it sticks out like that.
Yeah,
it's like a porcupine trying to protect that day.
You're welcome.
UFC 200 how crazy is that?
When,
when do we stop counting and what point do we stop counting?
You don't see 441 well you have to know the numbers,
so cause I loved to 96 you know what I mean?
Without numbers.
How are you going to say it looks good.
I agree.
Yeah,
I guess there's so many shows.
What do you do,
man?
This is like fight night,
right?
There's UFC on Fox.
You were just on Jerry six 71 that's right.
That's right.
Now see the difference.
This guy looks like he's gay.
He's not as disciplined with his hands.
Jeremy Stephens is a knockout artist and he did.
He,
I don't know.
Did he not make weight?
That's an issue.
You're not.
You're right.
He did it.
And what does that mean?
What happens when you get on doc?
I think 30% 30% or 26 she knows more than you
have.
Your 5% 30% 30% of your fibers or 20% few windows.
Uh,
yes,
it does count.
But the thing is,
if there's one thing that pisses you off,
see off more than having a shitty performance is not making weight.
They'll cut your ass for not making way.
Anthony Johnson,
Andrew Johnson,
he must wait a bunch of time.
They cut his ass.
Dude,
tell me if you don't make weight,
man,
there's nothing that pisses Dana white and Joe Silva Sophomore except have just
been a real shitty performer.
But if you don't make weight,
man,
good luck.
We'll Connor had to lose her.
I had to drop like 27 pounds,
26 pounds coming in.
What happened to the Korean Zombie?
He went,
he joined the Korean military.
He's out.
He fought Josie Aldo.
I was there.
And you want to talking about killers role.
Hey Brian,
you wants to touch into the fight companion.
Sorry,
but I'm just checking to make sure that I'm not getting any,
uh Oh Bobby here.
Ya Know Bobby's right here.
Yeah,
no,
we'll text you next time.
Could there be a bigger killers role than featherweight right now?
Look at that.
I'll tell you who's my dark horse?
Max Holloway.
First of all,
he went to decision with Connor grant concert,
but he has more confidence now.
Remember when you did the Cub Swanson?
That's hallway is a fuck monster.
45 is so stupid.
Either young kids,
young,
young Hawaiian.
The pride of the Hawaiians cause he's at,
she's all Hawaiian,
isn't it?
Yeah.
They don't come a howly because Travis Browne the call Holly,
right?
Cause he's a white boy from Hawaii in Hawaii.
They call them hop.
Who Slash Kapa Haka.
Is there any more things?
Do we know anything more about the uh,
that situation with Tabata about him slapping his girl around?
Ethnicity is add dime piece.
I'll listen.
I thought at that time piece.
Yeah,
it's a little bit what island you from?
[inaudible] island.
You know what?
I'm a little confused about why she didn't go to the cops because she said on
Instagram what she said.
So all these are allegations.
First of all,
there's been no charges press.
And she said the reason she came out on Instagram's,
cause she doesn't want Travis to get arrested,
loses career or get his kids taken away from him.
She said he's a good guy.
He just whooped her ass,
which to me would mean you're not a good guy.
Well,
good.
At least she did that.
I mean,
at least she had to get away and said,
yeah,
hopefully she's safe now.
To me it's,
it's crazy.
The people with the comments like,
Oh,
you,
you whoa.
Like why would you do this to him up?
Take it.
You don't to get beat up by Travis Browne.
I do.
And I didn't have the balls.
Don't show my bruises on Instagram and he beat the shit out of me and I tell you
what,
she probably put up a better fight.
Oh my gosh.
She probably put a better fight then she got to use weapons down twice.
I took them down twice.
Almost broke my neck.
Yeah.
What can you do,
man?
He's a monster.
Can you imagine that guy hit you hard?
Holy Shit.
Can you imagine that guy hit and hit and hit and that girl was then dime piece.
Oh,
I use that term a lot,
Bobby.
Too much.
I don't even know what it means.
Hot piece.
You're a 10 he's a dime piece.
Mm.
No,
I wouldn't call him A.
Dot.
Dennis Bermudez.
Yes.
Here's my question also.
So if you're Robbie law,
if you're a Robbie Lawler and Rory Macdonald,
if you ask me what they're thinking,
I'm saying you've got to stay warm,
but the problem is you can't warm up too much because you don't know.
Do they know what around when they're going to find out exactly around.
They do.
Especially if you're coke or Maine or if you're on the main card.
So you know you have a very good idea.
You can time when you start,
you don't have an idea because especially when Bert was in the back,
I don't know how it's run now.
I haven't fought since Bert left.
So when Bert was in the back there,
you'd say,
Bert,
when I'm up and he'd say,
you're up around eight 30 so you won't be ready around,
you know,
Short,
warm up around seven 45 eight yeah.
I have a dumb question.
Well,
why do you do that warm up?
Yeah,
I would just like not move at all.
It's a bad idea.
Why do you want your body,
your body ready for?
No,
I don't want to exert energy now.
You're not worried about that yet.
Like optimum contraction.
Preach girl.
Failed your way up to optimally stretch and or shorts even.
Talk to me like that again on a podcast.
I will kill you.
I'll fucking question.
All right.
Take it easy,
man.
I thought you said you were a wrestler.
How can you have wrestled competitively?
Just kind of showed up and I did it.
He'd scallops on the map.
What the yellow stone did you do sports?
I was a swimmer for 15 years.
Where did you,
where were for the Philippine national team.
Athletes are talking how much you take [inaudible] I guess you got yourself a
new,
a new girlfriend.
Dammit.
Philippine national team.
Holy Mother of Lord.
Wow,
that's right.
You know who I met recently and had dinner with with summer.
Uh,
she was an Olympian and summer Sanders.
Yes.
She's great.
Great Story.
I said,
[inaudible] you swim.
this is so funny.
Her husband.
I said,
first thing I said,
her husband as I go,
I go,
um,
uh,
he looked like he was in shape.
I go,
you look like your shape.
You'd work out.
And he's about my age and my buddy goes to,
he's,
uh,
he's been on three Olympic teams.
He's one of the greatest skiers up all time.
Oh,
right.
Okay.
And then I,
then I see her,
I don't know if she's married,
literally swear to God,
you know,
I like this.
I go,
got some arms on you,
man.
Your arms look good.
You look like you stay in shape.
Uh,
Brian,
she's,
uh,
she's one of the fucking greatest swimmers.
I want to goals one,
two golds.
I think so.
Yeah.
She stayed in shape to like Dara Torres.
Have you seen her body there in her forties?
The swimmers,
swimmers big dough too much.
Too much.
You're biting off too much.
They're not as big as she is about five,
eight.
But the new age swimmers that you see now,
especially butterfly or missy Franklin,
Loren Landow trends,
missy Franklin,
she was 16 when I met her big girl.
And she's the Michael Phelps.
The girls?
Yes.
Yeah,
she was in college and she's out now and she's just making millions off
sponsors.
She was in college I think for a year or two.
Cow.
Yeah.
Beast.
This is a great fight.
Really good fats doing steroids right there.
That his corner man,
first of all,
his corner man should be a commercial or Tlt,
TRT and balding,
although in the very back is a good buddy,
Ryan Parsons who is jail sones coach Dan Henderson's the list goes on.
He was the head coach at um,
in Temecula for all those guys.
Bob based,
super beast.
He was on I think a six or seven fight win streak.
And then he lost alumnus.
But he's a monster.
I was telling him when he had six fights,
you need to start squealing like a little baby pig for a title shot.
You want six in a row,
son.
Where are we doing?
When is,
when is,
when is a guy named Dan [inaudible] going to get his shot next.
Thanks.
Guaranteed the next shot.
But he wants to fight before that and we dialed shill Jerry,
right?
No,
he fought a Modesto.
Oh God.
He said you get nervous.
He goes like,
what?
He goes,
I've all every every time and he's just,
of course he gets nervous.
Yeah,
but he is,
he looks like the car.
So look at me.
Everyone gets,
he just looked so gay man,
and he looks so gained.
All of them do.
Look at Jeremy Stevens.
Lou We went to,
they show Jeremy Stephens.
He looks like he's having the time was like somebody has or haven't finalized.
They're nervous,
but they're having the time and the lights.
Check out.
Southpaw,
official sponsor.
Speak in a south.
Paul,
a 50 sentence.
Give me on the phone.
The kid this week seen the movie cause I need to see it.
I need to see it too.
Then wants to go to the open tomorrow.
Let's go see him Monday.
Can you go?
I can't do it on Monday.
I'm most the only premier that we're forming Monday
as in singing a song with a band.
Have you done the Goddamn comedy jam?
And they've asked me a thousand times,
what song would you sing,
Bobby?
I said,
know what song would you say that having a song,
I'm singing,
I'm singing Mahler by dancing and I'm not ready.
Can you give us a sambo children nutter.
Look,
Ma,
I'm not mad at that.
Tell your children not to hear my words.
What the say Mumbo.
I'll give you $500 filings,
walkout song.
That is,
and I fought him.
Oh Shit.
Fucking real knowledge.
I know what that's going to give it away.
It's Gabriel Gonzaga.
Yeah.
Terrifying.
He beat him.
I beat him.
Put on a box boxing clinic.
Use My jab.
Used my reach that you always talks about and that we're not talking about
shitty gins out who we're talking about good guns.
That he's a beast.
That was four or five years ago,
right after he beat cro cop.
Right?
You find I'd be a cro cop.
No,
I beat,
I beat Gonzaga and I fought cro cop.
I fought Gonzaga after he lost her junior dos Santos.
Here we go,
guys.
Here we go.
Mother,
look at Jeremy Stephens.
Tell your children not long hallway you.
I could do backup vocals if you want to.
You could and I'd like you to,
well,
it was actually,
actually,
I want you to come because maybe I'll have you come up there and so we were
supposed to win.
Here is the favorite,
but it's close.
I think Bermuda is,
is a,
hey,
he's a pretty heavily favorite for us.
We're talking to them and man Mabo I don't want to,
Karen,
you're keeping man the dog for live.
Get you had him from the way.
They ain't Whoa,
oh,
oh big right hand in someone's bleeding.
And it's Jeremy Stephens
that looked like he got it from a headbutt trains at alliance in San Diego.
He's a beast.
Super hard hitter.
Crazy knockout artist.
That upper cut,
was that a left or a right upper cut burn?
Uh,
it looked like a right and now,
Ooh,
we got ourselves a real,
it's what I call it,
dog five.
Brendan,
you say dog fun.
I say talk,
fight.
Cockfight dog fight.
You know what kind of fun?
I'm glad I don't have to do this for a living.
It's just so scary.
I can't believe you've done this for eight years,
right?
I'm gonna have to,
I'm gonna have to force her retirement.
I can't have it.
You're going to force them to retire.
I just can't.
I can't have you and I do have the greatest job in the world now.
I can't cast when the shit.
Um,
did anyone see the video of Rogan that he Instagram out training with Mark Della
grotty hitting myths have,
did you see him kick?
Yes.
Body have these cases.
Joe Rogan kick kicks are scene us all though.
Shit like he was kicking I text.
I was like,
Jesus Christ man.
Relax on the kicks.
Crazy.
It's crazy.
It's his hips are so loose.
Della grotty can see game.
He's 48 kicking him and he can do both sides.
Yeah.
Pretty impressive.
How about this fight though?
Silence.
Everyone was thinking about throwing those kicks since he was 14.
We did taekwondo at a high level.
I've been throwing those kicks with since he was 14 I would,
I would pay money to have Joe kick in.
Like I don't,
I don't want that.
Oh know.
I want you to have a kick off our 2015 kickoff.
Brian Cal and Joe Rogan.
It's a kickoff racks a little bit.
What do you think your hardest kick my Aussie Rogan's is?
That [inaudible] will kick cause I knocked a lot of guys out with it.
They weren't athletes,
but oh,
here we go.
Here it is.
Look at Joe Rogan up here on the screen.
Kicking like a,
Oh my God.
Now Watch.
Now what's impressive is he can switch.
Watch what's Tele grotty.
Who's a world class coach.
One of the best in the business.
Look watches.
Oof.
Oh my God.
Left and right.
That's rare man.
He's a beast.
I gotta pee again.
Brian.
He's scared.
Okay.
You think they'd ever have a kickoff?
Jamie?
Never.
Never break.
Well,
Brian said he knocked a lot of guys that was spinning.
Kick I call bullshit.
Brian's in the bathroom right now.
So we're just going to call bullshit Rogan.
I actually competed.
Damn.
See,
oh my God.
Think God.
I opened up from a headbutt it cause I didn't see an actual know and he's trying
to set up or a head arm choke here trying to choke.
When do you stop it though?
Like when day,
if it runs into the ice,
when the stop is really fits under the eye continue.
No matter how big this,
well it depends on what the doctor things,
but if it's over the I can run into,
it's a tough spot up there is not two x two and dropped down.
It's not gonna run into that.
But when it starts running the eye,
yeah,
you're in trouble a lot of times too.
It's on Fox and has a lot of blood.
You,
you're playing a dangerous game.
Fox doesn't want all that blood.
You have to think about it.
Talking about the regular folk.
Oh.
Tell you what Dan Scott Brock and really turned it on here.
He just looked at the clock.
I don't like when they look at the clock.
It's a bad sign actually.
Very good that these phenomenal fight.
Yeah.
Oh,
exactly what the UFC needed.
snaps.
Oh my God.
I tell you what,
Joe Silva and Dana White during this match make,
and they knew exactly what they were doing.
Every single fight that they put on this card brings the eight.
It's exactly what you need,
especially when you got all eyes on Conor McGregor.
So people are tuned in for the first time,
I think,
just to see what this Conor Mcgregor Fella's about.
So you've got the Reebok kits,
you got these monsters slang in the gloves.
It's exactly what they needed.
Good for them.
Great Grand.
Wonderful.
Yet 10 octagon girls just in case
count.
Who's your fate?
Rock young girl.
You guys have a favorite ad?
The one,
I don't know her name.
Brittany baller.
Nope.
Uh,
there's enough.
She's American.
She's on this car.
She American,
I think so.
Brunette with beautiful body.
Well,
we sit beautiful body.
You illustrated big jugs.
I did,
I guess,
but she's,
they all have nice legs.
She looks like she,
her,
she Brazil.
No,
we're,
I'll tell you who's the sleepers that Carly Baker from England.
God,
look her up.
Carly Baker brings the heat.
Well,
Jay,
we got a legit producer.
James gonna.
Bring it up for you.
Carly Baker.
Carly banker brings the,
hey.
Oh,
she could make me a crumpet anytime.
Go ahead and look at her fell.
Soak that in.
I want you to soak that.
Not Mad.
And in person.
She is a smoke show spectacular in 2000 definitely not mad at her at all.
How could you be?
Why would you be my Lord?
Have mercy on me.
Yes.
Lock me up.
Throw away the key.
Now let me see that.
Let me see.
There's another one I want to,
if you don't know her name,
it's hard to look up in it.
But the USC girls,
no,
Brian crossed up caught it because I just don't like when they do.
Dumb post is like that.
I'm always,
oh,
I know.
I can't stand when they stand provocative like that in the post pictures.
That's so lane said.
The only gay guy in the room.
Oh,
such a rough sport.
There was a head,
but you're right.
That was a headbutt for sure it,
but yeah.
Oh,
she's got set of knockers on her too.
Hey Bro,
take it easy man.
Nice girl too.
Very nice.
She could.
It's Britney Palmer sugary cereal because Brittney Palmer there tonight or is
she taking self defense classes too much?
Is that too much?
Too much silence in the room.
I didn't get it till it's just now.
It's funny.
By the way,
Mister Bermuda says not slow down.
Slow down at all.
He's a phenomenal coach and he hurt his leg like bad hurt him.
Oh,
that might be a knee.
It looks like it's buckling a little for sure.
While he still threw it.
Ooh.
It might've been shitting on shift sometimes.
That'll take a little while.
Steven's recognizes it.
He sees it now.
Yeah.
Trouble.
Trouble in little China.
A lot of places.
You're over your phone.
He's got Jesus on the side,
which I didn't realize so I'm going to,
Steven seems he's got tattoos.
He's got holy ghost power.
First of all,
Jesus on bolts.
Oh,
oh,
oh fuck.
Oh.
Dennis Bermudez.
One tough son of a watch.
Good sprung out.
He's in trouble.
He's in big trouble.
If he lands take down,
it's going to be fine day.
What?
Great fights.
I can't remember that stolen card was this guest crazy.
I can't.
Last time I was this excited for card.
A little Asian people down there.
Joe Rogan,
the bottom right there.
There's some empty seats in there.
That's interesting,
right?
Well maybe the ground snacks.
Brian could be grabbing snacks.
Brendan,
this is the first fight.
I felt like that's the third.
He's that that knee is not doing well.
That,
I don't know if it's his knee or shin.
He's definitely messed up though.
He's definitely in trouble.
Three round fight,
right?
Yes,
sir.
Out You can see is in trouble.
Same dre.
Steven knows it and he keeps kicking there.
Jeremy seems to do it inside Kik
because it's there because he's not moving.
You're not mad at the way those uh Oh you don't manage is tight shorts.
Brian Dennis fills those things like,
oh,
his legs messed up.
He's not knocked down his legs giving out on him.
Yeah.
His leg is in some serious trouble.
Oh Man.
It was a nice,
good,
good Greg Mowgli.
Go Google him away.
Oh Great.
He can take a sharp kid meets his leg,
man.
So it's looking worse than it is when you can be.
He can't.
He can't put weight on it.
So when he gets here,
he's off balance.
He's falling down.
This is spot.
That's why you see that was such damn good.
Lord.
This is a violent filing situation.
Blood.
I know what Stephen's is hurt.
How about that?
Now Stevens has hurt.
Bermuda says,
hey,
based.
Hey,
good luck.
Given fight of the night out performance of the night with all these fights
tonight.
You know what?
That ring smells like Serena Williams.
It's fucked up.
Turtle boy.
Oh Man.
That's so you're saying Serena smells like the octagon?
Yeah.
Hmm.
You're awful baby.
Come on Bobby.
Racism.
It's nothing.
It's just an observation.
Yeah.
Like some people smell like shit.
Oh you give me a high five marine.
You're not you.
You can cut this out.
I thought that was a karate chop.
Karate Chop.
That's a salt.
Oh good Lord.
Oh boy.
This is an amazing fighter.
Amazing flight.
This is the best way we've seen tonight.
Offset harm.
Sat and Brendan,
you're not,
you're not wrong in saying this guy should be con.
This guy is a huge threat.
He's as good as anybody I've seen in the 45 pounds of Bermuda's.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Him and Connor would go,
oh my God.
Well,
let,
the thing is guys so durable,
this weight classmates can't sleep on anyone.
Oh,
he's doing this on one leg.
You can see you can't really push off on this.
Take down.
Wow.
Look at his meathead.
Going to look at them.
There's the odd young girls.
Every 2012 of them are cheap to fly them in it.
His UFC fight week though.
It is.
It's important tomorrow,
right?
Yeah.
There is the ultimate fighter finale.
Jake Ellenberger,
Stephen Wonderboy Thompson,
your main event.
These boys are fricking durable Europe.
These boys are working.
Um,
I'll tell you the best,
the most excited fight I'm looking forward to on tomorrow's card is Michelle
Waterson.
If anyone knows who Michelle Waterson,
it's their first fight in the UFC.
She was fighting Vic that one 15.
She's a little beast.
She's awesome.
Oh,
Jackson member.
The cyborg thing.
Pick the fights.
I did see Cyborg.
She knocked that ground like 40 seconds.
Then called Rhonda Out,
but you know what she does now?
She said she called me.
She stayed out and said,
meet me at one 40 I think that's what's going to happen.
Just make one 35 and shut the fuck up.
How can you call out a champion and not walk?
Go down to her weight group.
Well then you can't call her out.
Then you can't call her out.
Then guess what?
It's not for you.
Move on now is a business to say,
find me a catch weight,
Laura,
that that wouldn't make sense for Rhonda because it's like,
no,
there's no crap for Rhonda guys,
guys.
She's the king or queen and I should shut this up Bob guys,
guys,
this fight is,
this fight is unbelievable.
Unbelievable album.
I don't understand how when I really don't understand,
I'm not being silly.
I don't understand how you can take those kinds of shots and keep going.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I mean,
especially Steve and Shama guy who was knocking dudes out at 55 and then cut
down to 45 which the same power.
I'll tell you what,
man,
his leg is.
Jag,
look at Bermuda's [inaudible] gang blood dope right now as we speak,
because he's just so easy.
He doesn't need to say you guys are the accusations.
My man,
he doesn't read.
Email is passed.
Every drug test.
[inaudible] leave it.
I'm just saying,
can't say drug dope house.
You see?
There it is.
There's that kick.
Ooh.
Ooh,
You know what?
Yeah,
he got dropped there.
Boom.
It's right on the fucking Shin on this chin.
Whooping like a neck one.
A loss.
Oh,
Mike Tyson with a terrible shirt.
By the way.
You're talking probably the hardest hitter ever.
He's up there.
It's a great fees up there.
People say George Foreman,
but Mike Tyson's up there.
I'll go with Tyson.
No,
actually they broke it down scientifically and George Foreman's number ones.
Hardest hitter as your boy,
your boy,
John Brenkus.
John Bray.
We go boys.
Here we go.
This is the fight of the night so far by far.
Hopefully these next ones.
Look at this,
bringing his leg around.
Bring us communities is a rough fuck.
Bobby,
I want you to take,
I want you to taking your writing more seriously after this hobby.
I want you to start training.
We're going to start training you to fight in the one 25 w how much do you
weigh?
170170270 oh,
snap these needs.
Do you need to stop it?
They didn't stop there.
Oh Wow.
I told you.
I told you went for Jeremy Scott.
Holy Shit.
Good Lord.
Just spitting bloke.
We get to point out Mike Tyson.
Wow.
What a freaking fight.
Damn.
And there's Tyson.
He is not that now.
Highlight of his life right there.
Right in front of Tyson.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Amazing.
Damn he is crunk too.
They tell him to jump on the icon or if you jump out of it,
you're going to get fined.
What don't,
I mean no one ever gets fined really
on it in Toronto and they didn't do anything.
He got so excited.
Well,
yeah.
Everyone gets excited.
Oh,
it's over it.
How do you time that?
Ah,
Oh,
you know,
I'm practicing knees from now on.
Holy smokes
making it.
You use it.
You use it at the end of the fight.
They should stop the fuck way.
Way Too many shots mentioned needs tonight.
Right?
The last fight.
What a beautiful,
what a beautiful move.
Look at his corner men whistling out.
Look at him.
Yeah.
Late reaction and wow,
dude.
He,
he's,
he,
that's his,
that's his thing by the way.
Steven says is a striker first and then he's,
I'm knocked out artists.
Yeah.
He knocks dude's out.
Dennis Dennis,
his background,
his boxing,
but he does it all.
That was a phenomenal fight.
Excuse me.
I have to go to the bathroom.
Uh,
Bobby,
I'm going to help you.
I'm going to help hobby.
Hold on.
Help them.
I'm going to pull your pants down.
Dang.
Pull.
Hold your whiteness.
I hate seeing these guys lose pan.
It's so tough.
Jeremy is
what?
A feeling.
Look at the blood.
Look at that beast.
Wow.
He's a lot bigger than fucking Bermudez,
dude.
Well,
you still fight.
He was a big 55 are amazing.
Giant.
Knocked out artists.
Straight up head.
His biggest Joe Rogan's,
which is saying a lot.
Okay.
Wow.
What a fight,
man.
Powerful Joe.
Breaking it
down here.
Boom,
dude.
What's that?
Oh
yeah.
Oh,
the larger losses were
24 11 he changed his career and went down the line,
so I trained in San Diego.
All those boys.
That dude on the background,
I forget his name,
but he's a risk coach at.
He's one of the best wrestlers.
I mean,
got team.
The small white guy on the right.
There he is.
See Him.
Phenomenal coach.
Yeah.
Crazy coach.
Why don't feeling,
man?
What a great VOA five Oh five where's that?
505-FIVE-OH-5505 why does it sound right now with Kirky,
Albuquerque,
Blue Yuk.
Brian [inaudible] boss in the hall of fame,
obviously Quirky.
How Albuquerque up sprays never went down to Jackson's if that's where he's at.
Huh?
What a beautiful,
what a beautiful performance that was.
That was brutal because that fight of the night so far,
by far,
by far you go,
you could go fight it than it will cause now they don't do they do performance
of the night so you could go performance the night knock on the night.
I mean that was the kiss for performance versus like submission of the night or
all the same now.
So it's all just,
they give out I think three performances in the night.
So no more specifics?
No,
no more specifics.
But you can win more than one.
I think the,
I forget the exact breakdown,
but it's all performance of the night.
Okay.
And that's definitely performed.
Other than that,
boom.
Yikes.
The batch got this title shot by beating the other two,
four horsemen are force horse,
women's,
and then the only one left,
the fight was marina and she just got completely annihilated and Invicta in like
40 seconds.
What's that?
You want me to reset?
Because you're not paying attention.
I'm watching it.
I love it.
I love these promos.
No,
well I'm glad someone gets a number.
What's your car?
You put your heads headset on.
What's your calling his fight.
I like asking you questions like this.
She does that and the skill set to show disappointing.
She can,
can't you see how she's chosen for?
Then she went to one,
right?
So she's beat two of the four horse women and then marina was the fourth of
finished off.
She just got dominated in victim.
She got like knocked down like 40 seconds,
some shit.
So Rhonda,
his entourage.
Really it's just,
it's,
it's very similar to the entourage,
right?
Like she's Vinnie chase and the rest of the turtle and so it's tough.
It's tough man.
Please don't say turtle.
Why?
I loved her,
but I'm just saying that it's true.
Like Ron is a superstar.
Gaffer.
Turtle.
He made the most money.
Yeah,
turtles balling.
You never know.
Look at that card.
Well yet.
Struve Nogueira Shogun and still find little nog and big Nog are on that card.
Hey fellas.
Hey fellas,
guys,
you got to stop.
Good.
They're still fighting.
God,
you fought big Nog right?
I did.
Okay.
She,
she knows her shit.
She does know her shit.
Noguera has it been around forever?
They are legends as an athlete,
I guess you follow these things,
but she's so that intense.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Did you say as an athlete,
Dave,
she follows these things.
So if you're an athlete,
you've know mixed martial arts,
I don't know,
I guess she has a more of an,
I guess she's a fan.
Look at Ronda.
Look at the Dee Dee and sanity.
How do you get that intensity?
How do you get that dead cruel that need to just destroy god?
Damn.
You're just now seeing this.
Yeah.
You've never seen these highlights before.
They play these every day,
but I just don't get over it.
Look at her.
No competition.
She's by far hands down the best female fighter ever.
Not even close.
I'm a pretty good female fighter.
She would beat you in under 30 seconds.
Not even close in anything.
Fighting,
fighting related hand for pound,
punching Joanna or her punching and kicking.
Ooo,
that's tough.
Punching can shoot dominate you.
Um,
pound for pound.
Yolana I think Yolanda is a better striker than Ronda because you know she's
like a six time Muay Thai world champion.
Yes.
So she,
that's her background.
Now if they were to fight and say,
your honor,
they did like some super fight,
a catch weight.
Renault dominator,
she tossed her on her face.
Just grab her and throw her in the air.
Rhonda Jujitsu,
some of the best in the world for crazy male or female.
Cris Cyborg has actually been,
um,
like in the,
you know those lion fights?
Yeah.
She's been beat up by a lot of Moitai girl.
She got mad.
She got stopped by one of the top Moy Thai girls.
Yeah.
Oh,
Cyborg.
Yeah,
I heard about that.
She got beat up.
I want them.
Yeah,
it was a while ago.
But again,
it's such a different thing,
right?
It is.
Is this guy fighting right now?
Bobby?
What is he fighting?
Bobby Stetser woman.
Oh,
they did?
sorry.
Come on.
Beth.
[inaudible].
Ronda Rousey's fighting.
Oh,
that's great.
That's great.
I'm looking forward to it.
He's this tall or is this Lawler?
Mcnall yeah,
I can barely take this right now.
You're about to see fighting at its highest.
This is the last one,
Brian.
The last flight was tiny.
Did was fighting him.
Watch your ps and Qs,
but you're watching too.
How'd you get this in here?
You're watching the two best welterweights in the world.
That's right.
Please,
please hook.
Cross caught it as,
as,
as right up there with them all.
But yeah,
I think got some work to do.
I didn't.
Carlos condit might be the the best.
The best fight.
I think he'd be to anybody.
I love Carlos Condit Tamsen though.
Just in terms of just like technicalities,
like very talented side.
Incredible has this getting this is getting good buzz.
Well it comes out July 24th Brian,
so it's not as good as the warrior.
Well it's called warrior,
but you're right bro.
You know what I saw last night?
The minions movie.
That's it.
Good.
I fell asleep.
Walked out.
It was terrible.
Kids.
Well No,
no.
Pixar movies.
I love those cartoon movies.
However,
the minions are cool when you see me like clips.
Right.
When like despicable me.
They're funny.
An entire movie of that.
Too much.
I agree with you way too much to be honest.
Me and my wife said,
come to the movies with me and the kids and I go,
what is it?
Many minivans.
And she went like this little yellow people and I went,
I can't do it.
Hey look,
can't do it.
Little yellow people for an hour and a half though,
I can sprinkle them either.
Dope is dispute me.
They're funny now forward that 40 minutes of pure yellow guys and he gets very
old now.
Now Shop Ben shop you and I have to say
guys got damn man.
It's like I'm right here.
Come on Bro.
Bobby,
he just
yellower animated characters and you are an animated character,
but still there was a movie about a lot of you.
I'd watch it.
Thank you that Sam,
Sam Tripoli's joke about losing Bobby.
He,
he lost Bobby at the Korean Day parade and he goes here.
We're trying to look for a Korean and a Korean parade.
It's like looking for a needle in a needle stack.
Fucking prize.
Fun Day though.
Yeah.
What did you get?
When are you going to come on the fighter and the kid would need you?
What is that?
Well,
it's the biggest deal.
You don't ask me whenever you ask me,
I show up.
I'm asking you right now.
I'm going to be there.
What is it,
bro?
Real quick.
Are these graphics or he doesn't want me look.
No,
no,
it's you're in 100% 100 we're friends now,
man.
I need your back.
He's taken us back to the fuck you this graphic,
the new UFC graphic man.
It's really dope.
No Mad.
Not Mad at it.
Way Cleaner.
Right.
You can see that in the arena.
Like basketball games.
Yes.
I don't know,
but I'm going to say I don't know either.
No you can't because you can you see the glare off the side of the pillars so
they can see it.
Yeah,
but I don't like how they're doing a Mashup of the final two fights.
They should do men or they should do Rory and Lawler and then when the other two
come out,
like why are we doing a masters?
I tell you why I want Conor Mcgregor to win and why I was so nervous.
He won't.
Is that that I don't want hit this,
this train,
train,
this gate.
This can either be the star.
I love Chad Mendez and of course he's one of the best guys in this amazing,
but I just,
I want this hype train of cotton.
I want the movie.
Keep on cause I don't want him to,
I don't want to see what he does.
May lose this going to be embarrassing and I'd be bummed everything's going to
be,
I'm loving my show up though.
The new UFC layout is fricking dope.
That was sweet man.
Look at that arena.
Dana Dana White said this is the craziest arena fight ever he's ever seen.
As far as fans,
everything.
What are we going to say,
Jamie?
Yeah,
jumbo tron in the middle.
I feel like it's not usually a above the ring.
I've been there a few times.
I feel like its own thing or they've had it there but they always had it like he
had to look far away,
like off in the distance to see the screen.
Look at the 17 look at the welterweight it by the way.
I look at the welterweight division top five good.
45 and yeah,
it's just,
it's just a murderer's row.
It's so,
because Johnny Hendricks,
it's a bad beard.
Johnny Hendricks looks like an accountant.
He's one of the best to be Atlanta.
His beard,
he did.
If he showed up and he was like,
I'm your accountant,
I'd be like,
you look like a stocky accountant.
Cool.
Meanwhile,
he's one of the baddest guys.
What do you call this part of the face that's,
that's caused the,
it's called the bullseye for me.
When I kill people.
Oh
yeah.
Joe's got muscles.
He muscle muscles.
His muscles are muscles,
but kind of intense.
Joe Is,
he's so intense.
I'm good.
His mouth.
Tell you what though.
Best hype man in the game you had break down this call right now as far as the,
as a sports commentator.
One of the best ever.
As far as how much he knows his knowledge.
Yeah,
and train,
training,
knowledge me fights.
He's been in the game getting,
Joe's a very smart guy,
but he's also,
his secret is his intensity over a long period of time.
He's got the craziest discipline work ethic.
Like he was telling us,
he went to freaking like Chucky cheese or something with his kid is playing one
of those pop up games and he realized the high score is 500 so he sat there for
an hour till we got 500 well,
he goes,
that's an issue.
And he hurt his shoulder.
He gives good life advice.
I was like depressed like a month ago and he gave me really good life advice.
What did he say?
He says,
just look at life as a movie.
Like you're in a movie and you want someone to watch your movie.
I love that it's ice.
He said that to me.
That's what I say.
Oh,
I liked that too.
I'm gonna write that down.
Thank you.
Said that to me once.
He said,
he said,
you have to act like you're the star of your own work.
That's what he said.
Yeah.
And it really helped me out.
It's a really Joe.
Hey Bobby.
I just said,
I said this to him.
You,
you're one of the funniest fucking people ever,
and you're one of the Er,
you're,
you,
you have greatness in you as a comic.
And I've said that to you before and I,
you know,
very few people can do what you do.
So you should never be depressed about that year.
You have the ability to be one of the greatest comics periods.
So I send that to you before and I've said that to you publicly,
but I said that to you privately and now said,
so I don't want to hear your bullshit.
Why are you all you have to do is when you feel depressed,
it start writing.
You talked about what you're down,
Bobby,
we talk about why you were down.
Was it just things just like,
just go to a fuck?
No,
I just go through,
it's usually when people think I'm other people,
then I get really depressed.
Like Jackie Chan or no,
they'll go,
hey,
I love you on the hangover and then I'll go,
that's not me.
And they'd go,
yeah,
you are and all that.
No,
that's not me.
God tried to convince me that I'm him.
Well,
they'll go,
I love you.
Only heroes or I love you on Grey's anatomy and stuff.
I go,
that's a girl and stuff.
But yeah,
I know man.
Oh Jesus Christ.
You get people think you're somebody else.
No.
Okay.
Well you don't know what I'm talking about that you have a buddy year at funnier
than all those people I know.
But John is awesome and amazing,
but um,
does he do standup too or no,
he used to.
He does mostly sketch.
Yeah.
Ken Did on a standup DDI.
We on tour together and stuff.
Oh Wow.
That must have been a,
who do you think people think you are?
Brian,
Tom Cruise and Rory Macdonald.
I see.
Anything I'm writing Robert,
Robert,
Robert and Tom.
Has Anyone,
uh,
Luke Perry?
I don't want to talk about it right now.
Do people say that like you're Luke Perry?
It used to be,
I was like,
okay.
I see bit.
I'm older now,
so
he's always on me.
I think Luke is about 50 warm look them up.
I wonder what he looks like.
Everybody's younger than me and they are,
but right.
Bobby,
how old are you now?
Oh man,
old.
I'm 48 so roughly 43 dude,
don't then various Asian races.
No Asians and black people age so much better than white people.
Usually in general,
the each so much better.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Well
we've evolved.
Dammit.
Bobby.
Bobby there.
Luke Perry.
But look at how soft my skin is.
Tough.
Yeah,
I can see this to text my skin.
Look outside.
So you don't shave either.
How old is he now?
48 the same age.
He might look a little older than me.
Okay.
Brian,
does he hear it now?
Oh,
for sure.
Rather he looks older than you.
They.
Brian is Brian.
How?
How old is he in that top left picture though?
Cause if that's 40 at least I looked like,
can you guys have the same hairline for sure.
Yeah,
I can see it.
He's smaller than me.
Oh,
right there.
It looks about every bit of 55 you know,
he's a good looking dude.
Let's get to compare him to though it's a good comparison on people.
He should say it a a homeboy.
You understand what I'm saying?
Right.
You're,
I just want to say that you wanted to thank you so much.
I don't like,
uh,
compliments,
but thank you so much.
You're that human being.
I'm a human being and you go through depression.
You're tall,
you're top ups and downs.
Don't you?
Don't you get depressed?
I don't,
but
I've never seen Brian than kid count.
No,
I've never been depressed.
You know,
I hang out with this guy damn near every day.
We've been on the road together.
We've been through some shit together.
I've never seen them down once.
Don't bleed.
It drives me nuts.
You're an anomaly then because I always figured comedians were a lot.
Me Too.
Saturday boy,
morose 90%.
I'm going to kill myself to that.
He's a comic,
but he's special.
Bobby's really special.
Um,
and,
and the thing about cal too,
I don't know if you have this body,
but he has more than 32.
Kellen has more energy than me by far.
Yeah.
He's got,
I can't keep up.
I have to take naps.
I've always had crazy took naps and he was chilling.
Yeah.
I've always had a crazy amount of high test.
Have you ever get your testosterone,
which I must be high cause I got just like,
fuck all your hairstyle.
Well,
let's not get carried away.
He was just telling me that I'm losing,
I walked into the studio the day and I thought he's doing corn rows but is here.
I was like,
oh,
sick kill me and he's like,
no bro.
I'm just losing it man.
I'm just [inaudible] has cornrows.
I was like,
all right then we're cool corn rows.
You and Brian should go on the show naked and afraid.
I love you and I should do it.
We always talk.
I got to cuddle you and stuff.
Then I got to carry you.
It's fine.
Can you hunt Bobby?
I don't know how to do anything.
That's why I think I'll last though.
Just on his fat reserves alone.
Bobby's tougher than he gives himself credit for.
Where were you born and raised Bobby,
so none of your fucking business man.
Hey,
go do San Diego,
Bro.
All right.
Oh,
that's where he did a lot of street fighting.
That's right.
Your name was powerful for Ross.
Do it for us.
Sahabi now do they give you those bright green shoes?
Is that how it works for free?
I don't.
Those are,
I like them.
If you can wear them that way now,
now,
now you have to understand this guy is the fair yet.
Ooh,
chair and the,
now look at him.
He,
this kid has been groomed,
groomed to be the next GSP is going.
He does,
right?
You're talking about to,
do you want to talk about a guy who doesn't get nervous?
Fight Week Roy McDonald.
He doesn't.
He's like a serial killer.
I thought they should've named him the Canadian psycho kind of.
He hates that nickname.
What's his nickname now?
The Titan.
The red.
The Red Dragon.
The Red Man.
The Red King.
What does that mean?
I like,
well,
it's like from game of Thrones or something.
He's the red king.
The Red King.
He's young.
His Shit.
He's been groomed for this exact moment.
I like his disposition is introverted and sort of,
you know anyone who knows anyone who knows Rory is,
he comes out of his shell and he's a funny dude.
I wish people could see it can really,
he's actually really funny.
Super Intelligent.
I bet.
Yeah.
He's very funny man.
I bet he's smart as shit.
Very smart,
but he comes off almost.
He's like that.
He's
like,
he's an amazing fight.
Phenomenal there.
He's got everything right.
You know,
very hard.
It can be very tough to beat.
But a guy who can beat him as the guy like Robbie Lawler's beat them before.
But Robbie Lawler to just has that pressure man.
And you're talking about a confidence champion.
Robbie logged coming at,
look at them,
look how happy he is.
Look at him.
He's been here since he was 17 he said,
I'm coming.
He was fine.
That's that champion swagger son.
It's hard to get and when you got it,
bottle it,
he's a killer,
a murderer or look at him a murderer.
It was the best one seven year in the world
with songs coming out too with like you said though,
you can see the 70 pound belt just being on rotation with these guys.
They're all,
I mean they're all so fucking good.
He's just been doing it for so long.
Who couldn't get more relaxed.
You wouldn't look more relaxed.
We'll think about how many fights he's had in all the ups and downs.
Just talking about the guy who was a salty record,
really,
I think he's 25 and 10 but before he went on this tear,
he had a salty as recommend.
There's a time in his career where a lot of people were telling him,
hey man,
it might be time to move on.
There's a time when he didn't spar for years.
He would just go in there and train when it's spa.
Why wouldn't he spark?
Cause he cause the head trauma.
He thinks he's doing too much sparks.
He took time off and then that was when he was at pat milkshakes camp and then
he moved.
Well those guys are crazy.
Yes.
That's the old school days.
You're talking about Tim Silvia,
all those Major Matt,
Matt Hughes,
all those guys.
So now he goes from there to att where he's just flourishing,
tearing it up.
That's an amazing facility down there.
There's stitch herb dean,
who's that guy right there with the puka shells that probably king mo in his
corner.
That's phenomenal.
Wrestler,
Bellator fighter.
Phenomenal.
Phenomenal food here.
Might have some bars in the back.
You died?
Yeah.
I feel like your energy's dropping a little and you're good.
You want some coffee or some food or something?
All right.
Do you have a bar?
Well,
chips,
low blood sugar.
I haven't blown Blippar we're just getting,
we're just getting into the thick of it.
My man.
This is,
these are the fights.
These are well off now.
This is a three round or though or is it a five round five round title.
Fight him.
Shit.
That's what bikes are five.
We got to five round fights.
We got 50 minutes of fighting to go.
Why can't they go that long?
Can't they do endless rounds where like just whoever's standing is loud.
I think that'd be better if you hate ratings.
Sure.
Yeah,
I'd be dangerous.
It'd be,
it's too much.
It's insanity.
You'd have guys like calling and doing weird shit.
I Dunno.
I don't know if they're stolen would just be in Brazil.
Did have fights like Hickson.
That's spices,
man.
You can't do that anymore.
It wouldn't be a sport if you did that.
Oh this,
let me look at Bruce Buffer.
He's my favorite to watch man.
He gets crumped for these.
I brought my own Stevia to the studio.
JML If you notice that I brought my own Stevie get just have a bar there buddy.
Yeah.
How's that bar doing for you?
What?
I read it,
it actually doubles as an appetite suppressant.
Really?
It has to be real stevia extract.
If you get that Stevie at like Ralph's.
Yeah.
This is that.
All natural whole foods shenanigans that she is the best.
We're going to keep her.
Hope you don't mind.
Please don't.
Okay.
Cause I,
I walked down the street and guys hit on her in front of me because they don't
think that I'm dating her.
That's fucked up man.
I'm used to it.
I think you're like,
you're fricking like assistant system or something like that.
I'm a prostitute.
No,
no,
no.
Come on.
Or do you think that she's like a part of some government organization that
helps retarded walk across the street and stuff like this?
People think it's make a wish you had something like that.
Can you say no?
We kind of say like,
dude,
I'm not even lying.
Dudes will just walk up to,
I'm holding her hand
and she,
they think you're an assistant.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I Bro.
How do you think that I feel I had horrible,
I bet.
No wonder you're depressed.
You just made it
isn't new.
I can just eat rob guacamole.
There's got to be chips and stuff.
You have chips right next to you.
It's okay if Bri.
Okay,
thanks.
We can't turn the sound up for this,
right?
No Man doing a show.
I can't listen to the fights in silence.
Hey Brian.
Ever done one of these before?
I was set up for the other one.
Just a walkout.
I wish she was a button I could hit that just slapped you.
Did the K zero
whoa.
He's a,
he's an underdog in this cause.
The wrestling.
Oh,
that's what I think in the last fight was close.
Such a good fight.
How uncommon is that that the champion actually comes in as the underdog?
It's,
I mean it's pretty rare.
It's pretty rare.
But Rory Macdonald's very rare.
But the thing is the UFC getting,
it's getting so competitive these,
it's all about styles and match ups,
you know.
So let's say Connor winter night when he fights Josie Aldo,
I bet he is he going to be close if he's an underdog,
you know to me,
look at these guys staring each other down.
So with the UFC kits,
if you're the champ you have that.
They're all black.
So if the champion like black with gold,
I like it.
But I think for the non champs they have to make it different.
You can't have white,
both white and black.
I mean you're looking at your here in the face of,
I mean look at this.
Yeah,
we're looking Bro.
Oh my God.
No.
Roy is very smart,
very cerebral slash right there dude.
Super Cerebral fighter stands right there.
Best Jab at one 70 best jab at one 70 very soon.
Counter puncher,
Robbie Lawler.
Jesus
a bank.
Is there any way you can smack more into the milestone shit right now?
Well,
the holding hands.
Oh Shit.
Ooh.
No one hits harder.
That one 70 then Roy,
that's for sure.
I mean then Lawler talking about a knockout armor put you to sleep.
The last time they met,
he knocked him down.
Yeah.
Look,
I was looking at change and look at our boy standing right in range,
right?
Yeah,
right in the range of his rhinos.
What he's doing,
man,
I guess he does.
I'll tell you what's an advantage for if it goes to the ground VR.
Roy's Jujitsu is very high level.
You can beat a Metamorris,
beat the brakes.
I've got a guy,
minimal that I always do it at front of weird front kick that led sort of 45
degree roundhouse.
What'd you say,
Jimmy?
Under his elbow.
Lawler shorts.
He's got different shorts on then.
Do you know what?
I think it's like a different material.
I think it's a light black,
but looks purple to us.
Done it.
Who Do you think that's actually a front kick dude,
he's just holding them off of that,
right?
That his range?
Yeah.
He has on her arms killer Jab,
a phenomenal jab,
and the knees is those kicks.
Keep him at range.
How you that jab son.
Educated Jab,
I call it an educated Jab Brennan.
Oh,
all right.
Yeah.
Royce pouring.
Roy is not known as a knockout artist.
Roy Wins.
It's going to,
you know,
it's gonna be TKL later in the rounds.
I think
that,
but the thing about Lawler's a,
he's fricking damn near impossible to knock out,
especially lately.
And B,
he just hangs around and if he lands one of those shots,
it's night night.
Well that's quite the Mcdonald's.
So close to those hands.
Yeah.
They like,
as soon as he gets in with and range,
he's eaten a nice,
stiff Canadian jazz.
What are Nice,
but the thing is,
is Rah Rah Robbie Lawler's take down fence is so damn good.
Especially she early on.
So I bet we see Robbie just pick them apart for a little bit where mountain and
start to come in for a take down.
Right.
By the way,
it's thrown everything so far.
Robbie throwing a little bit.
Yeah,
this is,
this is Rory Macdonald's time.
I agree.
I think it's just time in Canada needs a champion.
Rory McDonald is the most skilled fighter here.
He and Carlos Condit.
That's going to be the SEC fight.
You.
You know they fought before us.
I do,
but Ron Donaldson.
Very different fighter now.
Yeah,
but not as high.
Whispered that.
Bobby.
I liked how you wish you whispered.
I listen more,
but thank you buddy.
Oh No.
My voice down one.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you who doesn't want to be a celebrity.
Oh,
Roy Mcdonald's and carries just a fighter.
Hates being noticed.
Hates me in a celebrity.
I love him.
He's a true fighter.
Even more lovable.
Oh true fighter and love the finer things in life.
Loves a nice suit.
Nice pair of shoes.
Likes his lady cars.
Loves a nice pretty young lady.
Quiet killer.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
stud man.
Superstud I'm very impressed with that kid.
Great Kid.
And I shouldn't call him a kid.
He's a man.
He's the future of the UFC.
You know why?
Because he doesn't have a background in wrestling in taekwondo.
He has a background in martial arts.
He went into the gym at 12 and start training mixed martial arts.
That's why he's so good at everything to stay dedicated to it.
You're talking about a black belt in striking ilcs jabs of black belt.
So the black round boxing.
Oh Hey look at Royce add on now you see that?
Yeah,
he has monster dude.
Well,
well we'll see.
That's the thing.
So certain guys have exclusive deals like Rhonda has exclusive,
right?
We'll see a monster on Connor shorts.
So I think certain guys with the big companies get additional ship cause Roy is
also an exclusive sponsor with Reebok.
So he has a different deal than the rest of the guys.
He just signed with them.
Actually.
I think this is so weird.
Brennan,
he's holding them off that hand like that.
I'll tell you what impressed me that yeah,
of course Roy's Jab and hold them off and all this.
But that takedown defense by Robert and Jesus and he was in tight Robbie,
freaky,
that left hand and Robbie stops right hand or that right that,
that,
that left hand is that you don't know if it's gonna be an uppercut or the
straight right.
And that he's a south paw then.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's a south Paul Bryan.
Yeah.
I didn't realize his entire career has been the south wall.
That's hard to fight,
right?
Or is it you just adjust and you stay on the outside of that foot.
It's hard though.
Right?
South Paul's are harder to fight cause there's not,
there's a lot more traditional fighters and our south poles,
so it's,
it's very tough,
especially when they're at such a high level.
Like Robbie
got s swat that the key to south Southview the key of the South Pole,
you see that left foot,
you want to stay outside Robbie's right foot.
Yup.
And,
and avoid that left hand come over that Jab.
Right?
No,
you want to use straight writes straight rights or how he stopped the South Pole
and a big right.
Kick your head to the outside.
So that's one.
One Round for Rory for sure.
And this is going to be frustrating for Robbie because he's gonna be eaten us
all night.
Yeah.
So he can't sit there and eat these jabs and kicks.
He's got,
he does not give a flying patoot he can just sit there and pick you apart when
round round,
round Haitian a shit.
But now Robbie,
right?
You're talking about conflicting styles.
Robbie just needs to land one to win this fight.
I hate,
I hated that round.
Did you?
I hate it.
I loved it.
It was boring.
You know what?
You're the majority,
everyone thinks it is.
I got that shit was blocked.
Why this level of fight to be that technical and use your jab set up kicks.
You're watching.
Now I get positioned where they're stepping,
whether it,
it's like the Floyd Mayweather Pacquiao fight.
Everyone's a guy.
Hate that fight.
True fighters like,
oh my God,
that fight was amazing.
They get gas.
They can see where the circle and let's see,
I can see how [inaudible] around.
It's like,
all right,
the level of technique,
the way they're measuring each other.
And and where,
how they're positioning and stuff and your margin for error with these guys.
All clinic watching him southpaw worries if we're standing on the outside of
that Jab and trying to use this,
right.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
His foot.
Watch how his foot is going to be on the outside and watch their feet,
man.
Yeah,
he's done.
It's a weird,
you don't want to tell the guy that if he doesn't pay it doesn't work.
What?
Sorry,
Bro.
Bro,
I'm trying to teach you lessons.
So when guys call you out with your girl slept around,
I'm going to take you as my,
like my protege bro.
So when guys draw him a picture of Brendan,
so when girls start fricking or when guys start heckling you with your girl,
you can just walk back and I'll just say this is Brennan shops girlfriend.
That's what he's saying.
Rob is going to have to make some changes here,
man,
because what he's doing now,
staying outside.
I love his movement here.
I love the footwork of Robbie right now.
Changing it up.
You have to,
otherwise you get picked apart by the reach of Roy McDonald
County ran.
I was giving me shit for reach.
I won't shut about reach.
Yup.
Well we found a guy who's going to use it.
That's right buddy.
I'm sorry friend.
That's all right pal.
You know you've got it from him or I spent a lot of time in my job.
Well,
a lot of time with them on one priority is my Jab Jab man.
It's just rob is going to have to make some money cause he can't stay outside
and he's going to have to start.
Risk is amazing.
What a job we'll do.
Like how it just,
you just can't do much when it keeps it.
That's good.
Good.
That's what fiber furbies tube or doomed did to Cain.
Valasquez just kept his giant space kind of view.
I think Roy has the Best Jab,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
The last time I saw job like this was George Saint Pierre.
Yup.
Great.
Granted they have the exact same coaches that come from the exact same camp.
I love this.
Oh,
don't we don't want start trading.
Let's get that job back,
son.
Look at these kicks right in the face.
Just these were reading and say,
I don't understand how for greasy over doom was that big of an underdog in terms
of just the betting.
He's always an underdog.
Two guys in the last five years previous to that sugar cane,
such a piece,
but I'm saying like they do have gone to war much more than I know and beat
real.
He,
you know,
he beat the brakes off.
Mark Hunt beat the brakes off.
Charles Brown beat Roy Nelson.
So,
um,
for doom.
It's a respect thing.
We were talking about the sun.
You'll see tonight when I was on there,
I'm Fox.
The thing is he just doesn't get a lot of respect and it's always an underdog.
It's like when the hell are the huge market.
It's crazy to look at how looking at Aurora just keeps,
he's going to do this all night.
You're not going to get them out of his damn.
You're not going to log them into a,
it doesn't have an answer right now.
He doesn't have an answer to what's going on and getting frustrated,
and I bet you we see later this round,
the third round,
you start opening up and taking chances and he's going to pay for it.
Or He's gonna Clip,
Rory,
right?
Well,
yeah,
Rory,
but you're right,
man.
If Robbie stance,
if you have a young kid who wants to get involved in MMA,
you show them tape on rural McDonald to you ever,
and then he says he does anything you'd say,
never get an MMA that's going to say,
or he doesn't eat a lot of punches.
He's very disciplined.
It's free.
It's also a mindset like it.
He's just,
he's a,
he's a serial killer.
You just need a,
he's a different animal for sure.
Different animal
just doesn't get,
his heart rate,
never raises it seems he's just going to choose does,
but he just stays cool,
calm,
collected.
That's why it's fine.
I don't want to hedge live in Brennan.
He's just standing there,
but just measuring shots,
his footwork,
that's getting them out of the way.
It's this distance control,
which is everything peripheral,
not,
not worrying so much about slipping punches,
but rather kind of being out of the way.
He's relying on his feet and his jab.
He's just big too.
He's big.
Oh,
well better pay attention.
Now.
Robbie Lawler is a champion for a reason.
You,
you,
you get so nervous with Robbie because you can,
you can connect with him.
Knocked out.
This is the wall.
He opened them up.
Oh Shit.
This is the one.
Come on.
We're Maria's fan.
That'd be great.
Roy is standing there taking it.
Damn it.
Look now.
Now look,
you got cut the champions.
Confidence Son.
That's trouble.
Oh,
good counterpoint.
You look at the chat,
they're eating some shots on my God.
Rory for sure.
Get out of the way.
I told you he was standing in there and within range.
Well Netball.
Now the champ found a little secret high fennel open in the kitchen as you call
it.
Kalin.
Yup.
He's in his kitchen kitchen or the UFC fighters.
She'd get a Tan.
They should get a Tan because when you're pale like that guy,
you don't look,
you can see the blood morning isn't always translate well though,
cause I remember Leo Machida not too long ago came in with like an ultra fake
town and I saw it like it was very odd.
By the way,
Rory Macdonald's taken some shots right now,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.
This why it's not going five rounds.
They continue this smile on his face.
Damn you got,
you got to give a Robbie this route one to one.
Probably when she say Jamie,
I'll get his face
for sure Robin.
Damn.
The confidence of a champ is trouble when we start to open it up.
Now he's laying his jab and as long too.
Oh Man.
Robbie Lawler shit.
He can take shit man.
He's so damn durable.
Yeah,
he took bunches from Johnny Hendricks.
I want to apologize.
The big rig.
What's up man?
The fights of the first one was bad,
but this is a second round was very good.
So I want to apologize.
You want a session?
He broke it.
He broke out.
He broke his nose there.
Uh,
it looks like an orb or law.
I wouldn't say his nose.
All right.
Well it's not good either way.
It's not good.
What's not good?
As you got the champ being comfortable and he's like,
oh,
hold up.
Because at first one and you're frustrated,
set round,
you're like,
well,
so we got one,
two,
one
motherfucker momentum's a motherfucker and fighting shit.
Dude.
Roy hasn't been in trouble in a little bit.
Oh no,
he hasn't man.
Oh Man.
Robbie Lawler is really,
look at,
they look at the counter on this fucker.
I wasn't sold on Rory before this,
but I really want him to know when no,
right.
But there's something about him that's just,
I try to be on bias.
We got,
damn it.
I suck at it till he was good at being unbiased or boy Joe Rogan kind of has to
be right.
Yeah.
Just fucked him up.
We got one to one.
What?
A fricking card.
He broke his order but over the bone or something like that.
Yeah.
It looks like an orbitals messed up and look at the champ frothing at the mouth.
Yeah,
that's what you don't want to see.
Okay.
What though?
We're in round three here.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Step over that fucking
God.
Robbie Lawler just keeps his eyes open and just sees everything cause he keeps
his eyes open.
Yes.
Oh these exchanges are where like,
oh,
you hold your breath like one shot to the chin.
Something's going down this route.
So I'm getting,
someone's getting dropped.
This rounds can be tele changer.
Yeah.
It's just a matter of time.
I don't like the way Ryan,
is he in the shot?
I don't either.
I think he,
I feel like he's coming in and getting caught when he comes in.
Well Rob,
hang for everything he throws.
Robby found his timing.
Yeah.
Robbie's found some niche on his timing.
And if I'm Rory,
I'm going to mix it up and shoot for a take down because what he's doing now,
he's getting starting to get ate up a little bit.
Damn.
And you can tell what the kicks and there's movement.
Robbie's just looses as fuck.
Oh.
Oh fuck son.
How about the Chin on our boiled Rory bread guy.
Big Donald Red King.
I don't want to look at the elbows.
Where is he is no.
Yeah,
they're getting close.
He throws his elbows.
His face skin ate up.
Oh right.
Tell you what,
man,
I don't care how good your Shin is.
You're not eating too many of those Robbie Lawler left hands.
Very Long.
Sounds getting drops.
Yeah.
Does
God dog?
How good is Robbie Lawler so good.
So fucking good.
He's the champion.
Oh No.
I liked the take down attempt.
Needs it.
He needs,
oh,
there we go.
Holy take down a fence.
Batman.
Holy take down the fences,
right?
Holy Shit.
Talking about a type of martial artist,
he talks about a high level wrestler too,
and Roy MacDonald.
Holy Shit on his face.
Oh my God,
my sister.
This is his nose.
His face looks like a Red Matt.
He looks like the red king right now.
Yeah,
that's an area we have to the attack.
One of ax kick please.
I'm telling Robert that not to whatnot don't burn down or what not to do it.
Nope.
Roy looks like the Red Guy.
I just watched if I came in from Captain America,
the bad school old guy.
That's what he looks like.
The Red Skull.
I think his name should be the red skull.
You can mark it.
That's crazy shit man.
Man.
His face is beat up.
Yeah.
Telling you something's going down this brown red.
Oh look at these.
Wow.
Whoa.
Suck it round.
Right.
We're trying to readjust.
Yeah,
cause the takedowns was nowhere near happening that took it down.
Okay.
Docker and Robbie Lawler and that's crazy that he couldn't take them down.
Not even close.
Right Roy,
you get to add that single deep to super deep and and W I dunno how Robbie got,
how did Robbie defend that?
What was that?
I didn't even see how he did that.
Just great.
Take down a fence.
Brown.
I'm not going to break down the wizard 101
oh.
Oh,
okay.
It doesn't matter.
His hands are up.
His hands are protecting himself.
He's protecting his body.
These taking those shots on all slow down a little this round.
Right.
It is the third.
That's the only natural.
It's mid third.
This fourth round is going to be a barn burner.
Oh,
Lottie shot.
It doesn't matter with Robbie Lawler.
I just don't see him ever.
Okay.
Getting,
I dunno.
He's talked about it.
Your career.
Resurgence at it.
He's sick.
It's like he's master.
That's like it clicked.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's a master of enemy.
Yeah.
Which very few are.
I mean,
the first round I thought robbers had made some serious trouble.
Nowadays for sure going to win this.
I just thought I was going to be a clear cut decision.
Oh,
it's a blocking.
I got to start taking on striking more seriously.
Brennan,
please cash out.
I don't have this kind of fucking,
I don't have this in and out.
I got to start.
I know you wouldn't see me out.
The problem is the other day told me you sparred and you didn't get hit once.
I think that would be a problem because those that elusive,
don't get me out of that.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm sure you're very similar to Floyd Mayweather,
but you have an inbox and very long.
If you're sparring guy who can't hit,
you might be time to switch it up.
But it makes me feel like I'm fighting Mayweather when I'm,
when I bought somebody who's never boxed before.
Um,
oh,
first time with your gloves on.
Move around with me.
Oh.
That his arms are off.
Oh,
what?
What that,
oh,
oh.
Oh Holy
Robbie.
Lawler's just got rocked here.
He did his every fight.
Oh my God.
Every fights like round of the year.
You got a new champion.
What does,
what the hell this guy,
car drivers.
Are you kidding me?
He's going to get out of the wrong.
Oh
my God.
And still going.
No worries.
Let's go.
Holy Shit.
You're kidding me.
That was around the house,
which I,
I
please don't.
Please don't run this month.
Oh,
amazing.
What?
And fight.
Wrestle grace.
Greatest UFC fight card I've ever seen.
Hands down.
How about Robbie Lawler still aiming to clam up,
keep his composure and come back.
It was sort of a delayed response to you.
I didn't think he'd,
yeah.
Holy Shit.
Sure.
He's gotten beaten up kind of bad before,
but still one.
Yeah.
Yup.
Rory Mcdonald is a,
an absolute killer.
He's tired right now.
Look,
he's breathing heavy.
They're both tired.
Right?
But he's still got the crazy in his eyes.
I think Mcdonald's or did it hit behind the air?
Yeah,
they bought a year.
So that's going to mess up your equilibrium.
Okay.
That's not bad.
That's not a chin issue.
That's nothing.
She just hit me right behind you.
So anytime you hit closer to temple,
right?
Like Tim,
like Paul area or back here,
right behind the ear.
It's so sensitive so it throws off my equilibrium.
So you can see I'm a little wobbly.
Oh,
it's not.
It's just,
it's different than getting hit in the jaw.
It's a completely different look.
Oh my God.
I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking the fuck out.
Oh
my God.
Oh.
Oh my God.
He's coming back
here.
You're talking about the biggest freak.
Oh my God.
My Lord Robbie still examining covered.
Ron was like,
oh shit.
Oh my God.
You're talking about a new champion.
Okay.
Oh,
McCarthy's McCarthy's going to have to stop this.
Totally.
She's don't.
Please go two more minutes.
Probably stop calling.
Oh,
here's another shocking.
Oh my God.
Another one.
Yeah.
He hasn't recovered at all.
When's the last time you saw a welterweight championship fight?
Is this,
look at Rory Macdonald.
The beast that he is,
I mean Hendrickson calories getting Hendricks.
All the twos gap was there.
This is nothing.
This is,
this is the craziest Shit I've ever seen.
This might be the whole fight card is the best.
Some of the best friends I've ever seen ever in UFC history.
Oh my God.
Rory Macdonald is.
Why is he backing off right now?
He's just getting his composure.
He's tired.
What helped me?
It's the fourth.
I don't give a shit.
You know who's winning this fight right now?
It's fair.
Macdonald.
Oh my God.
I thought he knocked him out.
No,
you went first to take down.
Oh my God.
This is just too much,
man,
man.
Boy,
they were close to stopping it there.
That was inches away from me and stop.
Come on,
boy.
Come on Roy.
He still looks wildly.
Yeah,
he's not.
He's plotting forward real Roy.
He's tired too.
He spent a lot of energy trying to finish them there,
especially in the third and fourth round.
Rory is really tired.
They're both really tired.
Brian,
but Rory,
he,
you know his gas tanks running low because he's tried finishing them,
so they're both buying time to fill that tank back on up.
Good Lord does it sometimes another kick.
Where would you say Bobby at?
Sometimes.
Do you,
does your tech not fill up?
She late.
Yeah,
especially this late,
but the thing is for guidelines and the Aeon to fight this long,
I would've told you it's impossible.
Wrestling and everything.
It's the craziest shit.
Come on.
We'll know.
It's not impossible.
Actually.
A lot of guys do find out when it's the hardest at your job,
so a lot of guys can fight this long.
The thing is for Roy,
when you know you're close to finishing the guy guests,
you don't even think about gas tank.
You get like this Reyes like crazy energy,
man.
It's hard.
I don't know where it comes from.
I would get gassed out just walking into the ring.
I'm guests that watching this shit that's sort of like psychological at that.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at her.
Good Ronnie.
Lot of coming back.
Look at this is a fight.
Every fight.
It's been a great,
this cards fucking incredible man.
Shit.
This is such a fucking,
I bet that,
wait until this and think this arena says Conor to walk out.
We took collar walks up.
I can't take this shit.
Might collapse.
The feed might just break down.
Goddammit.
Rowers fucking really tired.
Roy has got less than the gas tank right now,
man.
You,
you will not find a fight or more durable than this fucking Robbie Lawler.
Jesus Christ.
Insane.
Oh,
oh.
Oh look at this.
Why would he do that?
Because he's a good rep to when the round.
Yeah.
I'll tell you.
Talk about take down defense.
Good God.
Even this tired,
he's able to insane fucking scene.
Rory.
This is a brutal fucking,
and this is insanity.
Yeah.
There's no tougher going this route.
Tougher job.
Who won this round?
Brennan?
I still think be 100% can you fight if you have aids?
No.
You can't play any sports.
I need professional sports.
You can play well with HIV or hepatitis.
Magic played a little bit with HIV,
Hep C,
well no.
You get blood tests for every fight you have.
Hep C,
you're not fighting now if you have anything,
any blood disease,
you're not fighting.
He's not a dirty word.
His mouth or do you see us look at Robbie's lip?
It's split all the way up.
Is it really?
Yes.
Look at his lip like the joker,
like the real life.
For Real.
He's right.
You gotta.
Oh my God.
He's still going back to that head kick that wobbled.
His lip is literally cut all the way up.
Oh my God,
that's not good.
I just saw a chunk of flesh cuff.
All my both of them.
That's a good swept up.
I think I am.
I think Dana White's going to be like Oprah.
You get a bonus.
You get up.
How could he have you picked one of the greatest?
How can you pick one best,
best,
best by hands down best UFC I've ever seen.
What a way to kick it off better than UFC 100 it is
these two men,
these two gladiators.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Look at him staring each other.
Split.
This is unbelievable.
This is like 300 or something,
man.
Holy Shit.
And neither do I wanted to back down.
You're talking about fifth round,
20 minutes exhausted.
You may stop with,
they'll let you fight with up torn lip.
Let me say I gotta.
I gotta make a decision.
I got to,
where's my phone?
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I,
how about neither guy wanted to back down.
Oh my God.
So fucking nuts.
This is nuts.
Torn Lips.
Not Bleeding as much as Rory face though,
so I don't think they're going to stop it.
Roy McDonald,
he's a fucking beast.
Some of the craziest fighting I've ever seen in my life.
Oh Lord.
Able to take that.
Okay.
His face looks really Pale.
He's fucking tired,
man.
I hate when they're,
it just worries me.
Look at his,
he's,
he's looking at himself.
God,
Whoa is his nose is broken.
Look at,
look at that.
This man,
Jesus.
Neither Gardner I live out in either.
I would break and walk to the corner and blood out for blood.
20 minutes of destroying each other.
Look,
man,
Robbie Lawler is got the craziest cardio I've ever seen.
He's just not tired after all that.
He will.
Well,
whatever.
I mean they're both,
they're both
pretty tired.
I think their mind is carrying them over at this point.
You're talking about championship rounds now.
This is what separates the men from the
boys.
Can't say women.
Cause there's some bad ass women out there.
I don't know how you'd score this fight out.
So I'd say I'd say Roy's up.
God Dude,
it's tough man.
Look at this.
Whoever wins this round probably gonna win the fight.
Oh yeah,
you're right Brian.
Cause Roy one the last round last the one.
Well No,
it's Roy up through.
When those elbows in there,
you think it's three to one?
Is it two to God.
Oh,
what did he do that for?
You poked in the eye.
What?
It looked like.
It dropped him right on.
It's weird.
Roy just fell down like that directly in the middle of
the bull's eye that Brian was talking about.
I looked on holy,
holy mother of God.
That was the greatest fighting one 70 history.
It's up there.
I have to agree.
I have not say about that fight.
That was brutal.
That was a crazy shit I've ever seen.
Why fucking bad ass?
He was ahead on the scorecards and see that replay.
Let me see the replay.
I'll tell you what those fans in that arena are getting a treat.
Edward James Almost again
here does.
Let's see what happened.
I broke his nose.
Nose shattered into his brain.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
he's,
his nose was just so jack.
Oh Wow.
He just knows.
I'm guessing the bone probably pierce inward,
but everyone up he would have died like Roy knew.
Oh,
she's almost all his nose,
so he just dropped,
dropped.
It was all my God.
It's brutal dance.
That sucks.
That fight and don't change your career.
Now your nose.
What changing career at all at all?
No,
no.
Relax on the dramatic comments
at
his lip.
How about Matt Brown?
Number one.
Most knockouts in welterweight.
Wow.
Look at Anthony Johnson.
Fight that light heavyweight.
Now number six so that his lip,
he doesn't give a fuck.
Hell No.
He's the world champion champion of the world.
He he game feels lip.
Don't feel any of that.
After you have smooth 15 minutes after,
what do they do?
A drawing and rushing to the hospital right now?
Yes.
Dana's tell them right now.
He said he seen one of the greatest fighter.
I've seen.
Everything's all right.
You know you're getting a nice bonus check son.
I think they get a PR portion of the paper.
You so these boys about to get paid because this is Robbie Lawler is just
fucking incredible.
Look at his lip.
UFC fangirl available or it's going to be feel good when you have to stitch that
lip up,
right?
When your champions can feel great,
man.
You don't give a shit Brian.
Yeah.
What a fricking fight.
What a real champion.
What are real champion and I don't want to see Johnny Hendricks for the third.
I mean the last fight was super close.
Jesus,
Karen Woodley's third Whitley scurred.
I Dunno what they do there.
Let's hear this.
Hands down
ever.
He's the legend status now son.
We get the meat head in the back.
Two
do.
Damn his lip is.
What a great scar though.
How'd you get that scar?
Oh,
greatest fight.
Welterweight history.
Small price to pay.
Boom.
That's it.
Okay.
Oh Geez.
Extract is no,
I'd love hopefully aid they interview Rory.
Hopefully they do.
He's not a man of many words,
but hopefully they do.
Well.
Damn.
I want to see a third between them for sure.
Over.
I would love to see a rematch.
That's a good point.
He said that that's yours.
That's yours or fruition.
That's just wasn't one punch my life.
All these camps.
Yeah.
You want to punch like that practice.
We'll talk to you in 20 years.
He's been fighting for how many years now?
Literally.
Maybe 15 or men like,
like that's a guy mastered this game.
He's a master.
He's a black belt and he's a match loads.
Cm punk.
God,
I'd love to see you fight him.
Killing.
I'm not joking either.
Yeah.
I'm not a fighter as a problem,
so either is he,
but neither one of you have had a fight,
so why not do it Callin?
My Ego's too big.
It's hard cause I tried to do something easy.
Brother cheater.
He was governor of California.
Cheater.
What do you mean she had her watch cheat on his wife,
right?
Yeah,
with the Mexican.
With an x in nanny nanny.
Did you see the kid?
They had beautiful,
I don't care that you got all the Arnold genes
has the Gavin and he's rich and he's got any swole.
He has all the Arlo.
He's going to be the next Mr Olympia.
Meanwhile,
the other kids that he had with seeing a picture of his son is pretty cool.
What's his name?
Do we know?
Don't know.
Don't care.
Brian
friend of ours want to see him.
That little snake your,
how about that?
That's what he's called.
His name.
Delkine girls voice sneaker guys.
Top Baby.
Okay.
Turn this off for a second.
Is it?
I got the call.
I tell you
bro.
I don't know man.
This is insane.
I've never seen anything that when you're back there,
do you have the TV on watching these fights running or do you,
do you do that?
Everyone has the TV.
Why would you want to watch this?
Would it,
I guess just good to see what's going on and it's good to see that you know,
sometimes in your mind do you make it a bigger deal than it is,
you know,
and then when you watch on TV or like,
yeah,
I've done that kind of slaughter,
this kind of insanity,
that war now that sometimes that motivates you.
It's the worst.
If you see a guy go out,
they'll get not brutal knockout.
That can the first round.
Yeah.
That's a striking coach from team Alpha male.
Chad's going to be able to take down Conner.
Yes,
I think so too.
Dennis Zebra took him down.
Seavers a kickbox.
Yes.
Kickboxer this girl knows her shit
pretty wide too.
That lead leg is in trouble.
He can at least go for a single,
I taught her that.
He stands why he talks so fast.
We are growing.
I can barely take it.
I want,
I want to say it's also Salone and gentleman is a,
that'd be looked like such a long,
by the way,
Chapman,
this is in there.
You actually hired trans men.
There's to warm up before the fight.
Has Steven Seagal had a loss yet?
He's never competed.
No.
I mean like,
you know how he supports a fighter?
He always win.
Uh,
Yo know he supported uh,
Leo Machida when he fought Randy couture cause I warmed up Randy couture for
that fight and he got kicked in the face.
Hey,
you know what?
No one,
so that would mean he did support me.
Fuck,
I don't know.
He's undefeated beat Anderson Silva when it's like fall that he was there.
Right.
But that was not a true loss.
I feel
still lost though.
I don't know.
There's not too many people had led in my corner.
I,
I would tell Steven Seagal to beat Jon Jones did.
Jon Jones was like,
get the hell out of him.
He tried coming back celebrate when John Jones.
Yeah.
And judge was like,
no,
I don't know you man.
Really?
You're talking about a true champion and Jon Jones,
he just crawl up to a corner from behind and just be like,
hey,
we're just trying to take selfies and shit and get involved in the fight game.
Did you see his video?
Is he his Russia where he put on like,
these guys attack him?
He puts on like a in front of a cute dog toy.
He's like,
act like he's clarion.
Oh Shit.
He's a god in the Philippines.
Izzy.
I grew up knowing only Steven Seagal.
Wow.
What about John Claude Van Damme?
I'm not as much as Stevens.
That's disappointing.
You guys need some fighters in a wrangler,
Lee.
I mean at least John Claude van Damme.
I mean,
yeah.
Well we'll get you.
Oh,
look at him.
He was,
his face is like,
holy cow.
Wow.
I can't believe we're just now getting the main event.
What a crazy nine to five.
If you guys need to go and you're tired.
I get it.
This is it for everyone.
So for Conor and Chad Mendez right now or are they thinking we need to put on a
fight like after watching all of those a little bit.
Yeah,
there's a little bit,
but that's a question.
More pressure on Connor.
I was going to say a lot of pressure on Connor and gets you to the main event.
The main event,
this entire fight card is really around Connor.
The entire Reno's for Connor.
The UFC is invested all their marbles into Conor got us.
You got to number one,
you have to win.
Just win baby.
Right?
Well,
if he just went and Al Davis,
just one big hour,
now we were hyped for the offer.
So if Connor wins tonight,
especially if he doesn't convince and fashion,
he's the biggest star of the UFC has ever had bar nuts.
Right?
If he loses,
we're in trouble.
If he loses word trouble.
But I gotta tell Ya,
Brogan says night tonight for the UFC.
I mean,
what I mean as far as just fights that Rod,
that was the craziest shit.
[inaudible].
Now hear me out here.
As great as this night's been.
If Connor loses amp or it's not a win for the UFC,
it's been a phenomenal fight card.
If Connor gets destroyed,
yeah,
it's not fun right now.
We can talk all that shit and we're all buying into it.
But then if you get murdered by a guy on no,
and guys like Kristen,
Leah,
Chris Lee,
and that's nothing about fighting type quizzes.
Like who's this crazy?
My Buddy Chris Delea text.
Oh you got Chris Tega had a group text message.
Hey,
what's this Irish guy all about?
I just said,
I said,
you're not my friend Chris.
My mom text me.
You see,
she doesn't watch any UFC.
My,
that's how big of a deal this guy's again,
my mom tech sure of us.
My mom texts me and said,
you think the Irish guy's going gonna win?
Huh?
Were talking about fucking superstar.
Awesome.
Um,
yeah,
I mean we,
like I said,
it's been a great fight card and I ask him,
why is he a big deal?
Cause he won five of fights.
Well he's,
he's his flair overall person.
It's a package.
He literally is the greatest face of,
he's an international superstar when he speaks.
What's your Twitter handle?
Bobby Lee live when,
when he speaks,
he taught,
he says,
I'm a,
and the first round he knocked him out in the first year.
I've never seen a mouthpiece like this.
And you see you Boxton at Muhammad Ali.
Granted you gotta realize Muhammad Ali was,
uh,
was uh,
Olympian gold medalist boxer,
phenomenal fighter.
So when he talked,
we all see,
listen,
cholera has five flights and he has a small,
where I'll lead kind of charisma about him.
He still has a ways to go to before we call him Muhammad Ali.
But he's the closest thing to greatness we have right now as far as being the
complete package.
Would this be his biggest test so far?
Tedman not even close.
Yeah.
It's like he,
he does employ a phenomenal fighter.
No disrespect.
He's amazing.
Worldclass right.
One of the top notch guys Chadman is,
is a fucking monster.
Yeah.
I don't like the fight.
If I'm the UFC,
I don't,
I don't have him fight Chad Mendez.
Well,
who either fought Frankie someone else?
Nope.
Definitely not.
Frankie written pretty much the same.
It would have been the same.
Right?
Frankie Edgar Mendez.
Well,
I see.
I don't know if,
I don't think Connor would have beat Josie.
I don't know that Joe's,
at least Josie who had been a standup battle.
Now we're talking about Chad Mendez.
Frank Yeager time like two guys mixing it up.
Yeah,
we'll see you man.
Who knows?
Maybe Connor,
you thinking down he some sick Jitsu we haven't seen.
Maybe maybe defend it and knocks chat out.
Worst case scenario,
even if it goes decision and it's kind of controversial,
that's fine.
We can take that,
but if he gets knocked out,
that's what we don't want her.
Here we go.
Let's turn this up.
Dj.
Well chats coming out first,
right?
Or is it kind of coming up first?
I think Connor's come out first with chance.
The giant Irish flag in the middle of,
he has,
he has a,
what's your name?
Your favorite Barbie.
I love her.
An old Irish songs.
She's singing.
Oh,
she looks every bit of 70 sorry.
Is this a first for the UFC to the singing?
It's a life thing.
Never seen.
Yeah,
she looks at,
she has a grizzly pussy.
She has him in a lot of miracles and she burned the flag and Santa and live
tests a crayon.
Well,
she hasn't been on TV and I make it since you bring the flag.
I love her.
So much power of Conor McGregor got her ass back into the states is amazing.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
What is about to go down as the cool shit I hear?
She said turn that up.
She can't
hear.
It's like a boxing title fight now.
The almost stopped production is like,
I've never seen a production like this.
There's only one.
There's only one guy in the UFC can do this.
Conor McGregor.
Yeah,
off.
They remix it right now.
Could notorious that'd be sick.
There's tourists bother.
He goes by notorious.
Oh,
sorry.
Oh yeah.
Hell yeah.
You gotta be nervous here.
If you're Conor McGregor,
you gotta be nervous as Shit.
This is insane,
man.
Look at him.
Good.
Holy Shit.
I've never seen anything like this.
I've never seen anything like this color.
Usually.
If a guy is so arrogant,
it's hard to root for him.
Connor's guy who's arrogant,
but he wins you over.
You root for him.
I've never seen anything like it.
Look at them.
Wait for this crowd.
Wait until he comes out here.
Here we go,
boys.
Ladies.
I got goosebumps.
Oh my God.
This is amazing.
I bet you next idea is youtube
for real.
It's about focus.
It's superstar.
You too.
You too tweeted a picture out,
given thumbs up and had a big picture of Conor on stage in wherever the fuck
they were.
Oh Wow.
It doesn't get much bigger than that biggest star we've ever had.
He went to night by far the biggest.
I'm awful.
I'm rooting for Ted Mendez.
I get up.
I love Chad.
Chad at,
for some reason,
Conor has this factor where he's won me over.
I'm rooting for this guy he was on are on the firing kit podcasts.
He's the coolest guy.
I went to lunch with them in Venice.
It's,
he gets the game and he's a true martial artist,
very for him to win.
I,
I just picture myself being Chad Mendez,
his mom,
and then hating him so much because my triadic man,
they'd better have been shit on their whole history.
Well,
what named the last hero they've had as far as that athletics.
He's from England,
from regions.
English,
Irish are also the Irish.
Also.
Their history has been one.
Yeah.
Going to a quick history lesson for Connor comes out through huge.
It's a huge reason.
Yeah.
You have such incredible patriotism.
They,
I mean they jump on some shit on forever.
There are more Irish warrior heroes in this country of Irish descent than any
other nationality.
Fucking rough people,
man.
Rough people.
I'll tell you what,
man.
You know what?
The only thing I don't like about Connor,
the Tiger Tattoo on those beautiful abs,
it drives me nuts.
Dammit.
So goddamn good.
Looks like a Hologram.
It has to look like a tiger.
If you can get that tattoo,
I,
it can't look like a real tiger has to look like a tattoo,
like a sailor tattoo.
I'm rooting for this guy.
Do you know why?
Because my people in his people,
we built the railroads in this country all the time has did not the Korean.
So I want you to
be Irish fans are,
you're getting booed and you're fighting in Vegas.
Listen to him.
Oh,
oh,
here we go.
American as fog.
What?
Oh Shit.
Who is this zone?
Who is that?
Aaron Lewis.
A singer from stained was country music now.
Wow.
He's really,
he's a country singer now.
The guy from stain,
I had no idea,
dude.
Have you guys ever seen a UFC like this?
You don't see went to another level like God,
they're just powered up son.
Everybody's got neck tattoos and tats.
I got to start doing that.
Unless you get a fight in the kit.
That too.
Okay.
If we reach,
if we reach ten nine I was going to say 15 minutes.
Let's go 10 million.
If we reached 10 million downloads in one month.
Yeah,
we're at 2 million now and we're growing,
so if we reach 10 million,
you'll get a tattoo.
I make it a tattoo.
No,
no,
no.
You got to agree to it right now and check on it.
Okay.
10 million listeners trying to to it.
Holy Fuck.
You get a master Kim Tattoo.
You get a master Kim tattooed.
Definitely get her.
If I'd heard the kid tattoo.
Okay.
There's no question at f and K we get matched enough in Cape Town at 10 million.
Yup.
Give it up.
I like it,
brother.
This is on tape,
Bro.
It's all right.
We're building that.
Do I have a show to do,
by the way?
Here we go.
Here we go,
Bro.
Here we go.
It's comes down to these moments.
Math 45 okay.
It comes down to these.
Oh,
you're fine.
You're fine.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
All Flagstaff.
There I was flagging I guess phase.
Careful now.
Careful.
I would say just from walkouts.
Listen,
no one's more American than I am.
I'm an Americanist.
Fuck.
I hate isis as much as the next guy.
However,
if we're talking walkouts,
Conor won this battle.
Sinead O'connor.
I was crunk for,
I had chills.
I felt like crying.
I'm not from Ireland.
I've never been there.
Yeah.
That's the effect this guy has on me.
It's crazy.
Did he?
Is He?
I don't give me money,
dude.
Imani Dick
Tonight,
honey,
Dick,
man.
I'm Irish.
Like drink like,
like he's tricking us
tonight.
I am Irish.
I got a text from Rogan,
said,
hey listen,
Connor needs a back rub.
I need you to fly to Vegas.
I would probably go,
I would just probably the only guy in the world,
I'm here if you need,
if his hands get tired,
brought a backup just in case I can't go the full six hours.
I don't understand the [inaudible] behind rubbing your hands are warm.
Almost sad.
48 year old dying just to touch.
He's jacking off in the corner.
Okay.
At this,
let's go boys.
This is war,
not war.
I know you hate when I see.
See,
I hate when you,
right,
but this is,
this is as,
this is real.
This is pretty goddamn real.
All right.
This is a fight.
No one's dying.
Okay.
It's not war
to fight,
but for me,
I just get,
I'm very nervous.
I just want it to live up to the hype.
What I don't want to have happen is calm and get knocked out early.
I just want a good flight.
God,
me neither,
man.
Why fucking experience they,
I mean,
now Connor's hair looks not as crumped.
What do you mean?
I just feel like he's,
what do you mean?
Crunk?
I Dunno.
Do you know what crunk means?
Nope.
I just thought I wanted him to be a little more slicked up.
A little bit more.
Better looking.
You're not playing grab ass anymore.
No.
Now,
now here it is.
Here's all of
these.
So just when we're on the Joe Rogan experience,
Brian Kelly and we were taught Joe Stein,
Mount Ibs.
We didn't know they actually can use ivs.
There's such a backlash of fighters.
They can use ivs for this one.
Ooh,
look at him talking shit.
Holy Shit.
He walks the walk,
dude.
He,
what did she say?
Join Stan.
He walks the walk.
Oh my God.
Pushed October,
right?
October.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They should just get rid of that altogether.
What type of fucking dangerous,
not Latin,
not allow Nivea.
I agree.
Look at that.
Reach cal and boy.
I agree with what,
he's got a huge reach advantage.
And there are a couple of things to keep in mind here that that I believe I
might take down defense has is excellent but he's not been working on it the way
he probably should have because he didn't know he was going to be fighting.
What were you gonna say?
Why would they be opposed to ivs after the weigh in?
Cause a blood doping.
Yeah,
the plastics in the,
okay.
Yeah but I think it's more dangerous.
You take IBS away,
it's more dangerous I'll graders.
Yeah.
It's like you have to rehydrate quickly guys.
Blood dope and it's not as day.
It's not,
I don't know.
I don't want to get into it.
The more important issue is letting them be healthier when they can't wait.
Cause guys are always going to cut weight.
Correct.
Let's see.
Blood doping or guys correct not can wait correctly.
Come knock on your and shitty performance is,
I'll take my chances and most guys wouldn't blade open.
You're talking about the exception that blood dope.
Yeah,
for sure.
Relaxed water bottle.
Where the fuck your name is?
100% relaxed.
Herb Dean.
Best in the Biz.
Him and McCarthy.
Just take a read through a poet little Dick without like actually like
transfusing the blood.
I don't know what you're talking alone.
Urethra,
your peel.
No,
no,
no.
Like Epo is what you,
what causes you the more,
more of the production of red blood cells,
right?
Is there like a synthetic type of like EPO that you could versus trying to
actually transfuse?
It
actually is.
I'm sure.
Let me just,
I'll call Lance Armstrong up real quick.
I'm sure he knows.
Do you understand what we're about to watch?
In some ways the most anticipated fight in UFC history here.
I mean biggest,
biggest fight ever in the,
in this division.
He really believed destiny is on his side twice.
So good man.
Cause he what he says he actually believes that's why we're on board.
Look at him.
It's like he's fighting in Ireland.
You know they're going to Dublin next year.
They announced it.
Copeland,
you don't think he's fucking headline that card.
I,
I'm what?
Poor souls going to fight him in Dublin?
Nope.
He's still headline now what is he doing now?
What is this?
What is he doing?
That tiger tattoo really bothers me.
No,
no.
Flaws me cause the grass on the sides.
Why would we put grass on the sides?
What?
Ah,
the grass on the side for really bothers me.
I loved the tattoo on the chest.
On the arms.
He looks drawn.
He sucked.
Wake at us.
Look at him.
He's insane.
Oh my God.
Look at them.
We've never had anyone like this.
How comfortable is this guy in there?
It's where he belongs.
Brandon,
you now you're dealing with a 1% are here.
Oh you're talking about the number one
one 45 around the world.
Yeah.
It's Chad Mendez based.
Super Nice super beets that way class.
Oh did you see your I favor and Connor get into it
on embedded?
Yeah.
That for the weigh ins co or Connor and your I are walking down the hall and
you're out.
He like went to say congratulations and then something happened where like of
act like he was wrestling him and then your eyes like mess around and Conner
wasn't messing around and they had to separate the two of them choking at first.
Look it up,
talking shit.
Right.
Oh my show.
I'll tell you what though.
Chad's never fought a monster.
Look,
look at him.
It's go time.
I'm talking shit talking shit.
I've never seen this.
Oh,
this calibrating.
I mean fighting a beast,
dude.
Holy Shit.
For sure.
Don't get knocked out in 15 seconds.
Look at him.
Oh Shit.
Holy Shit.
Amazing.
Oh Shit.
Well,
oh well I'll do that.
What's the question we all had?
Will you get taken down?
Holy Shit.
We got our,
well,
okay,
Chad,
isn't it?
He defended one.
Oh my gosh.
Jesus,
real quick.
Oh,
he got hit.
The thing about Connor's,
he in his lights,
he does get hit mass.
He does,
but if you get hit by Chad,
you're not.
You're not going to stick around very long shit.
Heads Cardio.
Given that very good slim that he hasn't had a turn can.
That's a good point.
I don't know if Chad was training before this.
I'm nervous.
What happened?
What are you baby Jesus happened.
Oh my God,
that scared me.
I thought the feed crash is Connor's breaking records.
Just kicking at him.
I almost had a heart attack.
Jamie,
don't Jesus Christ both the way he's acting.
What is going on here?
Nice.
Nice,
Do you know what Chad can't do?
Get into this game.
What Chad can't do is get into the corner having fun,
smiling,
eaten shots.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
Oh God damn it so much back.
Kicking him.
Holy Shit.
Chad looks intimidated,
dude.
He's dealing with a guy who hits much harder than you understand.
You don't understand what he's doing
and take them down.
You're talking about the European champion as a boxer.
He's a fucking accurate boxer.
I told you,
oh,
I just got hit.
It doesn't matter dude.
I'm telling you it's going to matter.
You can't get,
I agree with you.
I agree that I'm nervous.
The Anderson Silva,
you guys are untouchable.
I'm telling you that this,
can you do that?
I agree with Chad Mendez.
No,
I know,
but the first of all,
first of all,
I've never seen anything like this.
If Connor wins this fight did,
I'm freaking out.
Look at this man.
You know the pressure on this guy and he's acting like this.
We've never seen anything in sports like this ever.
Any professional league.
I'm telling you though,
he keeps getting hit like that.
He's not going to be funny.
You're talking about a high level wrestler,
two time.
All American,
All American.
I just want a good exchange.
I don't want it to be one sided.
I don't even care if Connor wins or
what.
What we can about what you don't want to have happen is this for five rounds
now,
this magnitude of a fight to work,
if he's going to take them down for Connor's good again,
back to his feet though.
No one keeps them down.
Oh Shit.
I might eat a few.
He's bleeding.
He's never been hit by a guy like Chad Mendez.
He's bleeding a little bit.
Me Know what you want.
Oh Shit.
I told you my prediction.
Fake take down to a huge over right Connor out.
It doesn't look good for Conor though.
This is a very different thing.
She got really Pale all of a sudden painkiller jumping ship already mad.
I'm not.
I'm just,
I'm nervous.
Oh,
he's,
he's hitting Chad.
Check and take shots though.
Look at that.
Body shots boob hotter.
Colton.
Both of them.
Are you
crazy?
I think they're both eating it.
Oh.
Explosive Chapman as a social explosive.
I think if it goes to the later rounds though,
it's amazing.
It's,
there's that fake shot body shot son.
He's fixing his hair.
I don't want to be crazy fixing his hair.
Oh,
it looks a little tired.
Nice.
Well if there's any question to,
uh,
Connor's takedown defense,
it's not great.
And now he's getting them out in side control.
This is trouble.
Trouble.
It's just kindness.
Weakness.
Well,
this is why you don't come and stop in a minute left this way.
You don't toss some Chad Mendez.
I'm
Chad.
He trains all year,
right?
Like he's,
that's the question.
No,
I,
when we talked to your,
I said the best thing about chat is he can get away from the game and take
breaks and reset.
So I don't know if he's taking a break because he wasn't supposed to fight.
Right.
How exhausted.
What's more exhausting holding the guy down or being on the ground like this,
uh,
being on the ground,
100% your heart rate's going like crazy,
but I read that he benefits from like a shorter camp to chat.
I'm not getting [inaudible].
I taught a week really?
Plus the week leading up to it.
They're doing a lot of press and all that.
So,
but you gotta think how much press confidence,
thinking much.
Press Connor,
dude,
for these fights.
You're talking about it.
He was on,
fuck.
He's doing interviews nonstop.
He had an a tortoise come on.
Fox Sports.
So this is one round of Chad.
This could happen every round man.
If he keeps taking him down,
that's going to happen every round looking at this elbow.
Oh,
that's not good.
Oh Man.
Well it doesn't have this.
He doesn't have an answer for that wrestling.
I know.
Hold on.
Ah,
I don't want to see him lose with all this shit.
Go.
He had Sinead O'connor fucking singing them out.
They might have been a bad omen mood.
I feel sick.
I love Chad.
So if Chad wins,
I'm not going to set,
I'm just,
I'm just saying,
man,
you have the whole fucking country behind you had the whole UFC behind you and
they give you the worst matchup possible off 12 days notice.
Does that sound like a smart business decision?
Do you think that was worse for him?
Right.
In terms of what do you do when you say you're going to wrestle,
you're going to find a giant fucking killer wrestler on 12 days.
Oh,
you're supposed to buy more Thai guy real quick.
Hey,
we have the worst papa possible match for you.
Here you go.
Could you still want Sinead O'connor singing out?
No pressure cause you to going.
Did he have to bring in the training part?
No,
it's too late.
It's too late on 12 days.
You see him point.
All this stuff is fun.
He shouldn't be doing this.
All this stuff is cool if you will.
As soon as you
know it's,
he's big.
This is big and I know,
I know.
He's just watching.
The thing is not going to say no,
he can.
He can.
The thing is can't chat.
Keep this up for 25 minutes.
Great sprawl.
Grace was,
she had some Jujitsu there.
He's got his hands down.
Brennan.
He so much longer though.
These kicks
chairs can be tough to not go.
Oh,
I don't know what.
Oh Shit.
He's learning it.
Go now though.
He's letting those shots go.
Oh God.
Shit dude,
he's wrestling is nonexistent.
That's exactly what we were worried about.
Every Conor McGregor fan goes,
yeah,
why am if you give him a wrestlers wrestling good enough.
Well,
when you're talking about top of the food chain,
what?
Chad Mendez,
you can't get them off you.
It's going to be tough man.
Yeah,
and especially as the fight goes on.
Cause like Dennis Seaver,
listen,
he's not Chad man.
He's not going to hold you down.
Conor Mcgregor's popped up before.
You're talking about the Chad fucking Mendez with Elvis for days and as the
rounds guards can be tough for him to stand up.
So do we get this for 25 minutes?
Is this what you want on the biggest fight ever?
I don't.
It's frustrating,
man.
I think it was poor and I
lose ground.
Get grounded down this way.
Hard to deal with that,
but we got tee shirts,
sales on it.
That's a lot of money,
my man.
And you're going to tattoo as soon as we get 10 million downloads.
Now if he were people hate us,
are going to listen to see you get attack.
If he loses me,
great,
but he's not an American man,
American,
so I know.
I know.
But what the fuck is wrong with you too,
honey?
Dictus into this whole thing.
I've been listening.
This is his 20 minutes.
His that
you can't fake fighting.
You can talk.
He's a way better striker,
but I've,
I think that Mendez,
the more tested fighter in my opinion.
Yeah.
Well you're a hundred percent correct.
That's why I,
when I gave him man,
this 12 day notice,
you've ruined it for me.
The biggest star ever,
potentially the biggest star ever in UFC history.
Now the entire world tuned in to watch him win and now you can get,
is this,
all we can do is enjoy the hold card here,
right?
Let's stand.
And Mom,
can you stand them up?
No,
you can't Brian,
because he's landing huge elbows and controlling the fight.
You can stand them up if you're Conor Mcgregor's fucking Finn.
Yeah,
this,
oh,
those are good elbows.
He's saying back to the head,
but I think you all know,
I think he's complained about one of those hits.
You can do that.
See how he's covering his mouth so he can't breathe.
First of all,
you want to talk about a gas tank when you're a wrestler and you're a hundred
was the hundred and 45 pounds.
You really don't get tired when your background's wrestling.
So that factor,
the factor of this is,
is Conor McGregor.
This is taken away his power,
his gas tank.
So the later the rounds go,
the worst is if you can't get up in the first and second round,
you're sure as fuck not getting up in the fourth and fifth where to go.
I don't know,
Chad Mendez,
he still like this for the rest of the ground and Oh,
and by the way,
if you can't stop and take down the first and second,
the third,
fourth,
and fifth,
the take downs get way easier.
Yeah,
true.
You're right.
God dammit.
Why did you do that to my boy?
Yeah.
You still need to boost your sales though,
cal.
I'm sorry.
The Chapman has is my hot stick to that.
What is not doing a lot of damage on the ground?
He is.
Look at his fucking face.
Those elbows are doing work.
And guess what?
This is using all of commerce energy.
Yeah.
This is what happens.
You train for a Moyie Thai guy and then they throw you the gnarliest fucking
match up on 12 days.
Notice.
Dumb.
It was dumb.
Yeah.
You just ruin your fucking golden boy in my golden boy.
What if I started crying?
I feel like crying even though I'm going to win the bet and my prediction.
I don't want to be right.
It's a okay.
Real quick team Alpha male.
They get a hold of your neck.
You're in trouble.
This is embarrassing.
We get some,
oh shit.
He'll hold his neck.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
oh.
He might go.
Yeah,
there we go.
He's tired now.
Oh my goodness.
I think China is our,
it's very tight.
Oh,
back up his friend.
Oh my God.
No.
Sorry.
There we go.
Back Up.
Chad.
Don't don't call anybody in chats.
Tired chats.
Tired.
Oh my God.
This is what happens when we take a fun and 12 weekday notice.
Yeah,
she cards.
Oh Shit.
Dude.
Don't show Chad's exotic.
He Won.
Dude.
I got to get all the short sale
shit and the second fucking Holy Shit.
Oh my God.
He's
the biggest star in the UFC has just turn this up.
Turn this off.
Oh my God.
It's too hard to
notice.
He's a champion,
Bro.
He's a champion.
He's a champion in the second fucking Bro.
But good lesson learned for him,
I think for Connor Kelly.
It's tough on him.
You wash the Chapman is Aldo fight at the two and what I saw was him standing in
front of him the whole time and I was like,
no way.
Look at him.
Yeah,
he does eat shots.
Oh,
he's murdered him.
No,
he's crying.
Who's,
who's The lady with the nine?
His wife.
Nope.
Dude,
he did it.
He did it.
That's insane.
He was out too.
He's such a bad ass.
It's such a bad,
the reason you got to like this guys,
cause he's a real dude.
Real guy.
Drama.
Let us now look at us.
Look at this.
Let me come over and hug him.
Watch he's in.
Be grateful to him too.
He's great.
Greatest UFC.
Calm down.
No,
he's,
this is why he loved Connor.
I don't want to go.
He won't shake your hand or just going talk shit after this.
There's respect.
That's the sports
dude he taught himself to be.
That's your biggest champion of all time.
Hands.
Right?
Well,
he's an intern.
Champions.
He stands to be the Lord my Lord.
How the UFC is breathing a sigh of relief
to look at this and it gave him a new kit and gold king.
Yeah,
he gave him the gold kit right away.
Look at Brendan.
Look at,
look at,
look at.
Look at no place.
Spot out of it.
Who that looked like?
It hurt his neck.
I feel like that's where that,
that's what caused them to cast a fighter.
My Lord.
Catch him with these shots.
Tell you what,
I'll never doubt Connor again.
Ever in my life.
Jose Aldo has gotta be worried.
Oh he hit cause he's the hardest here.
That one 45 told you he's the hardest hit are period.
Different game puts guys sleep dude,
you can't deal with those kinds of punches.
Sure as fuck can't sit there and eat.
And I saw that he just ate him.
If he got up and just called my Lord my Lord the whole 12 days,
notice
if it had gone past three that Connor would have won anyway.
He's just gone.
Oh my God.
Insane.
Best UFC fight card ever.
Connor.
We're not worthy.
I can't take the money for this year and I'm going to give you the money.
I'm going to give you all the money when we are releasing turbo shirts.
How crazy.
Turn off what from asa?
Akira.
Yes.
Well she's a friend of ours.
I'd like her to be friend of mine.
She's been on the show.
She's great.
Not Turbo sled.
Uh,
Callen started,
we started talking about the show and then people went turbo slut shirt.
So we were making turbines,
which she says,
mom,
I might have just gone honey.
Dick too.
Then I'm telling you is if his mom called her honey diction.
How overwhelming for Connor.
I'll tell you what.
This motherfucker so good.
I might buy a Reebok kick Connor shirt and I hate those because they can I be
asking Brendan,
we're team Connor.
Give it up.
Come on Bro.
Gimme gimme my fucking mind.
You even get the shrivel slit sales is the craziest shit.
What's he going to say?
The entire nation,
but is it park?
Wherever you want to sip on me and follow me.
Someone's mind.
Don joined the middle of it is so much media to tell the child around the world
twice and two morning guys.
It was all day.
It was so many.
So miss.
Too much man did they did too much with them?
Yeah,
yesterday.
So emotional man.
I'm like emotionally in me too.
Me Too.
I've never been emotionally invested in the fight of a guy who,
God,
it's like we got so that's his dad and mom right there.
Yeah,
this is mark not back and look in different stuff.
Right?
For an older lady who's with me.
What was that?
Pop suited up?
Pops is pretty hot too.
Protect from this style of opponent.
God,
I've been gifted a title shot,
Gunnar Nelson.
It was supposed to be protected from,
oh he's,
it's true.
It's true.
He proved me wrong.
Prove me wrong.
I'll eat my words.
I come in here.
There's my favorite fighter.
Hands Down
my family.
I don't know anyone else to come up with me cause we want to tell you.
Tell you Sarah people.
Since day one I have here with me now.
Can you think auto feels about this?
Watching all the went to toe to toe with Chad,
right?
Grantees chat on a full camp.
All the went toe to toe in a concert.
Cry,
right?
I'm emotional.
Like I have a lump muffly start crying.
I should.
That was a fight after the year,
right?
With Chad and part two,
part two in Brazil to this guy did it all its greatness.
Great fucking witnessing greatness.
Pure greatness.
This is why I want him to win.
You too.
Don't get me wrong,
but I can go off fucking day.
Oh fucking day.
I swear to God I can go like Joe got a little emotional there.
Who wouldn't?
Nobody can take that laptop show is a symbol as I everyone breaks
biggest fight ever.
Ever.
Give me your thoughts on that.
In my opinion,
the day
leading up to this point,
I heard that.
What'd I tell you can come in in this fight?
I heard Mcgregor's knee is fucked.
I didn't want to say anything cause I want to be a spoiler.
I heard his knees Jack where he should have pulled out the fight but he hates
the day will come.
But he stayed and plot you mean like ligament ligaments,
MCL.
Hrdy has a torn MCL.
I already asked to have surgery right after this and that's how bad his dude's
still comes to fight.
I wouldn't want it.
That's what a little Birdie told me.
I didn't,
I don't know if that's official.
So that's why I was picking chat cause I figured if he's hurt,
wrestler trouble.
Jesus guys,
thanks for
having me.
Okay,
you were off.
It was your girl in Deborah.
For anyone
especially
tough for Chad.
Man.
Poor Dude.
What if anything was surprising to you?
I mean,
first off I want to take on or for anyone except two weeks.
he was training for all though that entire time.
I mean that's a completely match up,
completely different batch of forum.
And I'm going to guys talk,
I mean hands down,
the guy's got the talk to back it up and uh,
you know what's awesome is these guys,
these Irish guys or you guys are crazy.
I love it mean I wish we had so much support like this with everyone here and
it's just unbelievable.
Crazy.
Um,
you know,
this is just completely off.
And for me,
this is the biggest fun at UNC.
What a stud to step up on 12 days notice.
Yeah.
He's a real man.
He has nothing and he's awesome.
No,
he has nothing to lose now
for you,
but taking a fight like this where you did have a full camp,
are there any regrets?
Is there anything right now in your mind?
Well,
look at Frankie trying to get involved.
You,
I don't have any regrets.
Don't ruin his moment.
Frankie
shows,
he's obviously next.
Okay.
What feeling do you get a chance to get into here and fight?
Whether it's a day notice there,
two weeks or a full camp.
You get in here to do it.
Uh,
you know,
I want to think,
Connor,
thank you so much.
That's awesome man.
That's how it should be.
Damn.
How about the ladies of Conor Mcgregor and then that
shit,
that guy's winning in life.
Glass.
Wow.
What is going on?
We just witness greatness.
People.
That's like watching Bruce Lee actually fight.
You're welcome.
But he's Irish.
Wow.
An Amazing night,
ladies and gentlemen.
Phenomenal fight companion.
Freddy,
look at,
look at Frankie.
Oh,
he's a,
he's saying,
oh,
he's saying congrats
or are you saying let's do this.
Let's do Josie auto.
100% is next.
I mean,
what?
October.
It depends if,
if,
from what I heard with rumors with Connor and his knee,
if he has surgery,
you're looking at a little bit of a layoff.
Yeah.
I think October would be too soon.
Yeah,
I know.
That's what,
uh,
Josie wine.
It was October.
God,
it was incredible.
It doesn't get better.
Bigger than Conor McGregor.
Thank you for the opportunity and the growth and I've learned so much about
really you were a member,
you have a different different outlook on fighting now.
I do.
And um,
um,
I tried to watch fights with them at home,
but I always end up watching alone.
Well,
you can call me.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry by that.
You can,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I know you don't like that,
but I figured I'd check and make it our new couple.
Oh No.
Okay.
I want to say thank you for having me here.
Where can
people find your brother Bobby Lee live on Twitter and Instagram is your next
spot.
You on the road?
I'm at the comedy store and the next week,
where am I playing baby Lexington,
Kentucky.
Beautiful Tuck.
He said,
come see me and Kentucky be,
it was really good to see you on the planet.
Thank you so much for having me on a kid soon.
I can.
Wonderful girlfriend.
Thank you.
[inaudible] get in the car.
Hey Man,
look at Conor Mcgregor.
Zero dead
killed it.
You guys kill how you do.
Go to go kill it.
Thank you.
Go go like five more,
right?
Yeah.
You killed it.
You guys are,
hey,
Bobby Lee in a smoke show girl brand.
Who knew a shitload about the USC shirt.
Did he faded out?
Bobby last two hours.
He didn't say a word that was tough on him.
Dude,
that was so unbelievable.
Greatest fight in UFC history.
Most exciting.
I mean,
I just don't know what to say about it.
I've never seen anything like that.
Just keeps backing it up and now backed it up in the second round with one of
the baddest dudes.
Tell you what can we had a bet tee shirt?
Do you like teachers sales?
So you're going to get the turbo sled sales.
Wow.
We get all the tee shirts and it's not a month.
We're only releasing one shirt in July.
Just one insurance.
That's with turbo sled.
So we have tourists letting black and gold coming out.
Yeah,
I like that.
Your grain black.
I can't believe we were making terrible sledge shirt.
I thought it was a horrible idea,
but when Rogan blasts it out,
then also Carol get,
I'll say will get us into where one,
that'd be perfect.
Should be,
you're not mad at this Joe Rogan shirt.
Jamie hooked me up dude.
I get one.
I am looking that,
look at that killer's row.
Ricardo Lamas just hanging in the back there.
Good luck.
Beaten Frank Gig.
Everybody.
Yeah.
Oh,
thing's a disaster.
I'm tell you what dog ordered my Conor Mcgregor Reebok Kit as we're on air air.
That should be coming in the mail.
I am a fan.
This whole event tonight.
I've never seen anything like it from the lay ins to the hype.
This is the first fight where when I was driving down here to Rogan studio,
I felt like everyone's rushing home to watch this fight.
I've never seen that before.
Is that Frankie Edgar Fighting Robbie Lawler?
Uh,
no.
That's Bj Penn.
Brian,
let's talk.
Let's wrap up the night though.
Yeah.
Um,
um,
no,
I think it was,
I think I've ever seen.
I bought Robbie Lawler.
No,
he did it.
That's Bj Penn to sona of bundling and slapped the shit out of the Cowen.
God dammit.
Why do we fight Robbie Lawler in the UFC?
I don't know.
It looks like it felon.
Let's wrap the show.
Get
most exciting the fight.
I've never seen a UFC event like this ever.
Ever.
From the singing,
from the hype,
from Conor Mcgregor being down and out and now guess what?
This sets up Josie,
Aldo Conner.
What's the chances they do that biggest thing.
Biggest in Ireland based thing ever.
Hands down.
Biggest fight of all time.
Yeah.
You tell Connor was worn out.
It's too much media.
Hey UFC.
Don't make them do that much media.
I'll tell you what though.
USC took a risk.
Put them in there against Chad and boy did it.
Pay Off it.
Pay Off.
That's like Ben,
I'm black and boy it hit.
I know that's been on double zero.
Very easily gone the other way and just killed the entire show.
How happy is the UFC?
Let's be real happy.
Am I?
How happy are we?
Yeah,
I think that's a wrap.
You good,
Jamie guys,
thanks for listening to the fight companion without the head chief.
Whoa.
Joe Rogan.
He took the,
you took the wheel on this one.
I'd say you're the captain.
Well,
when Joe was gone,
I got,
you know,
it could get a little wild or you never know my man to you and I were like a
captain co captain.
It's like pip and Jordan when it comes to fighting notes,
it's best that you take the,
if you take the lead.
Yeah.
Maybe the replay in the brown means.
Anyways,
we're going to get out of here.
The show where you can find this is the fighter and the kid.
I'll see Joe Rogan experience.
They're both great.
This is the fight to her companion,
the fight companion and joy.
Hope you got as much fun as we did wear out.
Yeah.